Guten Morgen, Kriya. Guten Morgen, Hendrik.
Also ich habe ja gehört, dass andere Podcasts so Einstiegs-Gags haben.
Ich habe gehört, dass andere Podcasts kommen und Bier trinken.
It works, bitches.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen was Eigenes.
Glaube ich auch.
Wow, wir haben ein eigenes Intro. Wir haben es endlich geschafft.
Yeah, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Herzlich willkommen bei...
Herzlichen Glückwunsch uns selbst.
Ja, wir sind so toll.
Wir schneiden das einfach raus, falls wir jetzt doch kein Tor haben.
Wir es nicht geschafft haben.
Ja, willkommen bei
Akronomisierbar.
Folge 2.
Ab wo ziehen wir? Wir zählen ab 0.
Wir zählen ab 0.
Das heißt, es ist Folge 2,
weil es ist die dritte Folge.
Naja, es ist Folge 002
und es ist offiziell die zweite,
weil die Nullnummer zählt ja nicht.
Ich muss ja noch mal sagen, die Nullrunde war fast unsere beste Folge.
Wir sagen mal Nullrunde. Warum?
Nullnummer.
Ja, aber ich verkackst auch ständig.
Wieso sagst du Nullrunde?
Weiß ich nicht, du hast es auch kack gesagt.
Das müssen wir nochmal zurückspulen.
Auch nicht jetzt.
Tatsache, ich habe Nullrunde gesagt.
Gut.
Ja, also wir sitzen heute wieder zusammen.
Wir haben es endlich mal wieder geschafft, uns zusammenzusetzen.
Wir sehen uns ja auch viel zu selten, muss ich sagen.
Ja, Leute, die so arbeiten, das ist total langweilig und blöd.
Ja, es ist, genau.
Und ich bin ja auch den ganzen Tag beschäftigt.
Achso, du auch?
Ja, genau.
Haben wir es uns eigentlich geschafft, für heute Themen vorzubereiten?
Ein paar.
Ein paar?
Können wir dauerhaft drüber reden?
Wir haben voll die Hauptthemen
und voll die Subthemen und voll die
Scrap-Thoughts.
Ich habe es mir muss zugeben, ich habe es gar nicht geschafft,
mich dazu zu belesen, was ich da sagen wollte.
Ja, wir können doch einfach so drüber quatschen.
Das macht auch den Charme
unseres Podcasts aus.
Das könnt ihr uns dann in die Kommentare schreiben,
ob das den Charme unseres Podcasts ausmacht.
Wir haben auch keinen einzigen Kommentar.
Aber wir haben Feedback bekommen auf Twitter vereinzelt.
Stimmt, wir haben auch Podcast-Catcher-Empfehlungen bekommen.
Herzlichen Dank übrigens dafür.
Ich bin jetzt umgestiegen.
Von BeyondPod auf Pocketcast.
Das ist zumindest eine Note.
Das kann zwar immer noch keine Chapter-Marks,
aber dafür kann es Silence rausstrimmen.
Und es kann sich eine Geschwindigkeitseinstellung pro Podcast merken.
Das ist nice.
Machst du das so dynamisch pro Podcast das ändern?
Ist viel Arbeit.
Naja, also es gibt unterschiedliche Sendungen, wo das notwendig ist.
Also gerade bei sowas wie, also es funktioniert super bei den Sachen von der Metaebene, wo dann teilweise doch mal eine Pause drin ist und die gehen ja mit so vielen super geilen Effekten drüber und machen das so sauber das Signal, dass wenn die wirklich einen Moment lang nichts sagen,
dann ist da auch wirklich
eine Runde nichts auf dem Kanal
und dann denkst du für einen Moment, warte mal,
hat jetzt mein Telefon ausgesetzt oder sowas
und dann überlegst du, krieg ich gerade einen Anruf und dann reden sie weiter.
Die haben auch wirklich so gute Mikros,
dass man da nicht das Rauschen, was nach dem Reden
ist, wenn das Reden aufhört, direkt aussetzt.
Das ist auch kein Hintergrundrauschen
beim Reden zu hören, es ist wirklich sauber, das ist schön.
Ja, ja, die gehen mit dem Kompressor drüber.
Das ist doch stark.
Vielleicht ist es bei uns mittlerweile auch so,
wenn wir das auf Funik durchjagen.
Möglich. Cooler Service übrigens.
Aber dafür,
ja, also für sowas ist es gut und für Podcasts,
die wirklich langsam reden.
Das ist schlimm.
Du hast so eine globale Einstellung, die Geschwindigkeit,
passt das für einzelne Folgen dann an?
Für einzelne Podcasts passt das dann an?
Ja, du kannst sagen, hier, diese Geschwindigkeit,
also wenn du so krass drauf bist wie du und das bei der
Geschwindigkeit alles hörst, dann kannst du sagen, hierfür alle übernehmen.
Es gibt so einen, wo ich es nicht mache, aber
alle anderen wird es einfach.
Es fehlt mir immer noch die Einstellung, dass das Ding merkt, wann Musik ist und wann nicht.
Ach, das wäre so gut.
Ich überspringe die Musik ja meistens, weil ich die einfach nicht
auf doppelter Gefindlichkeit hören möchte und mir zu blöd ist.
Aber es wäre eigentlich schon ganz nett.
Also die Podcasts, die haben meistens die CCC-Podcasts,
die sehr affin.
Das ist mir so ein Gedächtes hängen geblieben, als wir zusammen Auto gefahren sind
und ich irgendwie No Such a Thing, dass der Fisch anhatte
und du sagst, ach so klingt die Musik.
Das Intro, ja. Das klingt einfach so ganz anders bei mir.
Ich bin da so gewöhnt, dass das so richtig schnell läuft.
Das klingt auch angenehm, so wie es bei mir klingt.
Ich kann es aber nicht normal hören.
Das ist schon ein bisschen so
Chipmark-Musik, oder?
Es wird ja nicht höher, das wäre schlimm.
beschleunigt nicht.
Nicht der Pitch mit angepasst.
Der Pitch ist mit angepasst.
Du sehen möchtest.
Worüber wollen wir denn heute reden?
Was gibt es denn bei dir so Neues?
Es ist die vorlesungsfreie
Zeit, die in Anführungsstrichen
Ferien für im Studentenleben.
Das heißt, ich kümmere mich um
eigenen Scheiß und nicht so sehr
den Kram, den ich machen muss.
Das ist die geilste Zeit.
Ich habe mal wieder ein bisschen mit
meinen
Public Transport Bibliotheken rumgespielt, die ich
vor einer Weile geschrieben habe. Stimmt, ich habe gesehen, hast du
so ein Meta-Report rausgemacht?
Nicht ganz. Ich wollte
mal so einen Rapper
ausholen.
Dresden hat
die DVB und
das läuft alles, also Dresdner Verkehrsbetriebe, das
hängt ja alles im VVO-Netz mit drin.
Und da habe ich mal ein paar Bibliotheken in verschiedenen
Sprachen geschrieben, die deren Schnittstellen
rappen und dir die Möglichkeiten
geben, da Abfahrten zu tracken und
Trips von A nach B zu planen und so weiter,
was da alles geht. Und irgendwann
habe ich das ein bisschen angekotzt und ich habe ein bisschen
in die Ferne geschaut, was noch so geht
und da unter anderem diese Public Transport Library
gefunden von diesem Andreas Schildbach,
bekannt hinter der Öffi-App für Android,
die sehr, sehr stark verbreitet ist.
Und die nimmt halt solche
EFA-Schnittstellen zum Beispiel, wie sie
auch von hier vorhanden sind oder anderswo oder
auch andere Formate und rappt die eben
komplett als Java-Library weg und es ist
recht angenehm und ich hätte sowas gerne auch
anderswo und dachte mir, das wäre doch ein cooler Use Case,
das einfach in Rust zu
rappen.
Also einfach in großen Anführungsstrichen.
Das klein anzufangen und
das mit Rust anzugehen, damit man theoretisch,
das war mein Wunschdenken, ich habe das nur ein bisschen
jetzt mal drin rumgespielt, aber noch keinen
grünen Zweig gefunden, da eben
eine C-Library rauskloppt,
libpublictransport oder was auch immer
und das dann eben an anderen Libraries wieder rappt,
um das eben nur einmal die API-Spec
reinzukloppen und ansonsten
bloß da eben einen jeweils sprachspezifischen
Webber drum zu legen. Darüber hatten wir ja
vor einer Weile schon mal drüber geredet, bloß halt in kleinerem.
Aber ich wollte das eben
noch ein bisschen größer machen und hatte da zumindest mal
dieses Public Transport GitHub Organisation
Dings angelegt. Und dann habe ich
eine Mail bekommen von
zwei Typen, die ich sehr schätze,
die in der Public Transport Szene
aktiv sind. Das ist einmal dieser
Der Hürst, Jannis Redmann,
Der Hürst auf GitHub und
Twitter und der Julius
T irgendwas,
Ich habe den Nachnamen vergessen.
Ich bin ein Gruß an Nils an der Stelle.
Wenn er das zufällig hören sollte.
Das wäre cool. Viele Grüße an euch.
Ihr macht coolen Scheiß.
Die haben eben da, die setzen nicht,
beide Berliner setzen sich eine Weile schon damit auseinander
und bauen da krassen Kram,
alles JavaScript und sind beides
Leute, die meiner Meinung nach mit JavaScript
viel zu viel Spaß haben. Ich finde es unfair, dass
JavaScript, gerade die Node-Menschen, viel zu viel Spaß
mit ihrem Scheiß haben.
Ich finde es unfair, dass in anderen 10 nicht so
aktiv cooler Scheiß gemacht wird wie bei denen.
wie so dumm an, was die
ganzen Java-Leute
alles machen. Ja, aber das ist ja
ja, genau.
Nee, JavaScript-Menschen
sind coole Leute, die haben
eine geile Szene am Laufen, eine geile Community
am Laufen, die haben übelst viele coole Projekte
am Laufen. Es gibt vor allem viele JavaScript-Leute.
Ja, ja. Wahrscheinlich hast du
deshalb den Eindruck, dass es so viel geiles Zeugs gibt,
weil es immer mehr Zeug gibt. Es wird aber auch immer ausgereift
und man kann es immer benutzen. Da können wir später noch
kurz drauf eingehen. Jedenfalls
Repo erstellt namens Friendly Public Transport
Format und
haben gefragt, ob sie die
GitHub-Organisation damit benutzen können
für Kram und haben das, ich habe
die beiden damit hinzugefügt, eingeladen, meinen Repo hat man
rausgeschoben, bevor das irgendwann
mehr als ein Playground für mich
war. Du hast deins wieder rausgeschoben. Ich habe
meinen Repo aus der Org rausgenommen und zu mir selbst
übernommen und habe die, die machen da jetzt
erstmal Spar-Creams. Da hat das jetzt so eine feindliche
Übernahme auf GitHub. Nichts feindlich,
voll freundlich. Ich sitze da jetzt bloß mit drin und fühle
Aber es ist quasi der Inbegriff von Gentrifizierung, oder?
Jemand macht was auf, andere Leute kommen an, sagen, hier ist aber schön,
dürfen wir hier auch als freundliche Nachbarn.
Und dann zieht derjenige, der es ursprünglich auch gemacht hat, raus.
Ich bin ja nicht raus, ich bin da drin und schaue zu und lese alles mit
und finde es voll toll und freue mich daran.
Kannst du dir die Repo-Miete noch leisten?
Das ist ja ein bisschen so ein Name-Squatting, was ich gemacht habe.
Public Transport ist schon ein sehr generischer Name.
Ich meine, ich wollte auch ein generisches Projekt da reinschmeißen,
aber das ist halt auch nirgendwo hingekommen.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall, haben die sich damit auseinandergesetzt,
wie man solche Schnittstellen von ÖPNV-Betreibern
eben ein sauberes Format schaffen kann,
was weggeht von dem Klassiker GTFS oder anderen Formaten,
die es so gibt.
Was nimmt die VVO?
Es gibt beim VVO tatsächlich vier verschiedene Schnittstellen,
wo sie ihre Daten veröffentlichen.
Die haben leider noch keine öffentlichen GTFS-Daten.
Die geben GTFS-Daten an Google auf jeden Fall,
weil auf Google Maps hast du ja eben Daten.
Und Google macht das eben nur, wenn die GTFS bekommen.
Interessanterweise, aber die haben noch ein paar andere verschiedene
Schnittstellen, die habe ich auch alle mal dokumentiert,
was du mal von mir wolltest vor einer Weile.
Ich habe ein Repro erstellt, einfach nur namens VVO
in meinem GitHub-Account.
Und da einfach mal die Schnittstellen,
die ich kenne, dokumentiert, beziehungsweise
fehlende Dokumentationen stellenweise, aber mal
zumindest alles zusammengeführt, was es für coole Libraries gibt,
was es für coole
Kram eben alles gibt. Apps und so weiter.
Spielereien.
Und die haben da auf jeden Fall
dieses Friendly Public Transport Forum, machen die was
echt cooles und ich finde das großartig
will das irgendwann mal irgendwo leben sehen, das wäre
sehr wunderschön, weil GTFS-Daten sind zwar
cool und mächtig, aber es ist ein unglaublich hässliches
Format, es ist komplex CSV-basiert und
du kannst halt Scheiß
machen, mit denen du Ausnahmen definierst,
zum Beispiel der VB, die mal Vorreiter waren,
was öffentliche
Verkehrsdaten angeht, also die
Brandenburg auf jeden Fall,
die
haben ja von vor langer Zeit ihre
Daten veröffentlicht, die sie
eben anbieten. Und Open Data war da immer
eine tolle Sache und alle fanden es toll. Du kannst ja sogar
hier in der TU Dresden
in Lehrveranstaltungen wie Informationsvisualisierung
in der Informatik
arbeitest du teilweise mit VBB-Daten,
weil es einfach nichts Lokales gibt, mit dem du was machen kannst.
Liegt das immer noch daran, dass
die VVO IP-Adressen
aus dem Uninetz sperrt?
Das ist so eine andere Geschichte. Da können wir gerne auch noch drauf eingehen.
War witzig.
Wie kam es dazu eigentlich überhaupt?
Ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Der VBB macht aber bei
GTFS zum Beispiel so Bullshit, dass die
die ja eben alles, was sie haben, als Ausnahmen definieren.
Jede Linie steht als Ausnahme da drin.
Und so haben die nicht anstelle von 20 Einträgen in der GTS-Datei,
von wegen die Linie fährt da und da um die und die Zeit,
haben die 4 Millionen Ausnahmen da drin.
Was ist denn eine Ausnahme?
Du kannst so routenspezifische Ausnahmen,
also Linie 4 fährt normalerweise da und da,
aber an diesem einen Tag fährt die von da noch da.
Und die haben halt alles so definiert.
Und das Format lässt das halt zu, was ja auch sinnvoll ist.
Aber wenn die es nicht richtig nutzen,
dann wird es einfach nur mühsam und scheiße.
Ach ja.
Ist halt mit APIs, die kein Mensch richtig benutzt.
Also du hast jetzt hier irgendwie eine Zusammenfassung,
es gibt eine JavaScript-Limitierung.
Bei den DVB-Libraries.
Eine Python, eine Haskell,
eine Swift, eine Ruby und eine Go, die in der gleichen
Spalte stehen. Und eine Rust-Library.
Also bis auf zwei habe ich die alle geschrieben.
Also nicht mehr nur ich, sondern gerade bei der
JavaScript-Variante viele, viele tolle Contributor
gefunden. Ja, die kann auch am meisten, neben der
Python-Variante.
Die Python-Variante
ist recht witzig.
Das Haskell kann bloß zwei Sachen. Das Haskell hat so einen Liebhaber
geschrieben. Ich kenne ihn leider noch nicht, würde gerne mit ihm quatschen.
Die ist aber witzig, die ist echt cool.
Und die Rast-Variante kommt ja sogar von dir.
Die Haskell ist gefährlich, ne?
Kann man süchtig werden. Ja, ist eine schlimme Sprache.
Einmal damit angefangen, kommst du nicht mehr los.
Da ist leider sehr viel GHC drin.
Ja, es ist nicht so...
Go kann am wenigsten...
Die Go-Implimentierung sollte auch nur für meinen
Alfred-Workflow dienen.
Der ist auch verlinkt. Da hast du relativ schnell die Lust dran verloren.
Go ist eine witzige Sprache.
Ich gewinne gerade wieder so ein bisschen Lust daran, ohne was damit anzumachen.
Ist eine witzige Sprache, aber ich komme nicht rein.
Mich stört zu viel in der Sprache.
Mich stört vor allem so viel in dem Tooling.
Aber das ist ein Thema für ein anderes Mal.
Genau.
Das wäre sogar dieses Friendly Public Transport Format,
wenn wir unser Schema vom letzten Mal beibehalten,
unser tolles geschaffenes GitHub-Star der Woche-Rubrik-Dings,
dann wäre das auf jeden Fall mein erster GitHub-Star der Woche.
Das ist eher dein erster Shameless-Self-Plug der Woche.
Ja, aber das Friendly Public Transport Formal, da habe ich ja nichts mit am Hut.
Das ist ja nicht meins.
Und das ist mein Star der Woche.
Das ist dein Star der Woche.
Du hast mich bloß durch Rückfragen jetzt weiter darauf eingehen lassen,
weshalb ich da noch den sehr schäme Reserve Plug gemacht habe.
Tut mir leid.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Also GitHub-Star der Woche muss ich jetzt auch einen bringen.
Ja, hau her.
Ich habe zwei und ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen,
dass ich die so gestarrt habe, weil Freunde die gestarrt haben.
Und ich fände beide ziemlich geil.
Ich habe aber keine Zeit gehabt, mir genau anzuschauen,
was das macht. Das eine ist von
einem Bekannten von mir, Jan Lellis,
das ist auch so ein
Ruby-Nerd
aus Berlin.
Glaube ich zumindest, der letzte Stand.
Der hat
eine Ruby-Labor rausgebracht,
die heißt Unibits.
Und die visualisiert
unterschiedliche Unicode-Encodings
im Terminal und zwar farbig.
Wie spaßig.
Es sind ein Haufen bunte Tabellen.
Ich glaube,
sein Steckenpferd ist bunten Text
in Ruby auf der Konsole printen.
Diese Paint Library, mit der
Farben auf der Konsole darstellt, ist auch von ihm.
Das ist richtig sowas.
Das macht gutes Tooling aus für mich.
Ja, also bunter Text auf der Konsole ist
immer wieder was Schönes.
Das so als eins.
Und das andere, was rausgekommen ist,
interessiert mich sehr viel Programmiersprache.
Ein Kumpel hat das geliked.
SIG oder ZIG.
Also wie schreibt sich wieder anfangen?
Buchstabiert sich wie?
Z-I-G, wie Zigarette.
Unschöner Verbrech.
Is a systems programming language
which priorizes
Optimality,
Safety and Readability.
Safety Readability Check.
Was ist Optimality?
Keine Ahnung, es ist so.
Es liest sich ein bisschen
wie eine Mischung aus,
ich möchte jetzt keinem auf die Füße treten,
aber es erinnert mich an manchen Stellen
an eine Mischung aus Go und Trust.
Und es ist halt, du sollst in der Lage sein, C-Header direkt zu importieren.
Und viel mehr habe ich mir zu der Sprache nicht angeguckt.
Aber es liest sich sehr schön.
Die haben Iteratoren.
Die benutzen sehr viel funktionales Method-Chaining.
Und allgemein ist die Sprache eigentlich ziemlich schön.
Sie haben sogar schon ein kleines Tetris darin geklont.
Ich müsste eigentlich jetzt mehr dazu erzählen.
Aber ich habe so wenig Zeit, mir das Zeug durchzulesen.
Das ist traurig.
Das ist so beide Language Nerds.
Das muss man auch mit auseinandersetzen.
Wir machen mal ein komplettes Segment zu.
Ich mache jetzt hier den Cut, wo wir das vorbereitete Segment
hinzufügen.
Wo ich über diese Sprache rede.
Schön ist der Blogpost
darüber,
SIG is already more knowable than C.
Geht das aufs Google hinaus oder was?
Und das geht dabei darum,
dass die Sprache einfach
einfacher ist als C.
Das macht aber echt was aus.
eine kompakte Syntax, eine kleine
Sprache finde ich sehr wertvoll.
Das fand ich auch an Go so toll.
Ja, das ist halt bei neuen Sprachen immer so.
Im Vergleich zu solchen Monstern,
die
seit 20, 30, 40 Jahren existieren,
sich mehrmals zwischendurch neu erfinden,
Programmierparadigmen
über Bord werfen
und deprecaten,
aber nicht komplett aus der Sprache
rausnehmen, weil es muss ja mit einem neuen Compiler
noch ein 20 Jahre altes Stück
Code kompilieren.
Dementsprechend sind es C und
C++ heutzutage so fürchterliche
und gleichzeitig wunderschöne Sprachen.
Je nachdem, welches C++ du schreibst.
Das sind völlig andere Sprachen.
Das stimmt natürlich schon.
Ist nicht Rust auch so ein Kandidat, die sich komplett neu definiert hat
zwischendurch?
Ja, aber
das hat alles mit 1.0 aufgehört
und alles, was vor 1.0 war,
kannst du mit dem aktuellen Compiler nicht mehr bauen.
Spannend.
Die haben gesagt, wir wollen jetzt mal stabil werden,
wir schmeißen jetzt mal alles raus, wo wir uns in den 100% sind,
machen die Syntax lesbar und einigen uns auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
und alles andere.
Ab jetzt kommt additiv hinzu und es gab bis jetzt seit den 2 Jahren,
wie das raus ist, eigentlich keine wirklichen Breaking Changes.
Du brauchst jetzt nicht irgendwie einen Transpiler für den Code von 1.0
heutzutage noch ein modernes Vers zu übersetzen.
Das sind einfach ein bisschen...
Du hast einfach weniger Möglichkeiten gehabt,
aber die Sprache war es noch nicht gleich.
Das ist schön.
Das ist auch eine schöne Sprache.
So, jetzt haben wir das...
Um wieder an dem Thema zu sein.
Achso, das waren ja deine beiden Stars.
Das waren meine GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Ich möchte beim Schema bleiben.
Ich habe ja auch zwei.
Dann habe ich als mein letztes noch
ein wunderschönes Projekt.
Das ist ein wunderschönes kleines Spaßprojekt.
das ist gar kein Spaßprojekt, das ist ein
JavaScript-Projekt und was man mir da zeigt, dass die JavaScript-Leute
viel zu viel Spaß haben, ist ein Skript,
das den
San Francisco,
da wo du halt hingehen kannst, um
Tiere zu adoptieren,
die Seite von denen auseinander
nimmt und nach Katzen scrapt
und ich weiß nicht genau, wo die
Daten hernehmen, aber der berechnet,
was die fetteste Katze ist, die
gerade im Angebot
haben und gibt
dir die fetteste Katze,
das Profil der fettesten Katzen, damit du die adoptieren kannst,
weil fette Katzen haben ein schweres Leben.
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Fattest Kat.
Das ist wunderschön.
Ich dachte erst, das wäre so ein Textausgabe-Programm.
Ich habe es auch gedacht.
Ein paar Leute in meiner Timeline gestartet,
okay, Spaß mit Kat.
Ein berühmtes Kat, was auf dem
Paint-Jam von
Jan Lelis basiert, ist
LoL-Kat. Das ist das, was dein Text in Regenbogenfarben
auf der Konsole rausgibt.
Das habe ich auch mal genutzt, das ist toll.
Aber ich muss gestehen, ich weiß nicht,
was das für Daten verarbeitet
im Hintergrund. Wahrscheinlich, vielleicht haben die das
Gewicht einfach mit dabei. Ja, aber dann wäre es ja einfach,
aber der gibt halt so langsam aus, Weighing Cat,
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Weighing Cat, so und so,
Weighing Cat, so. Hast du das mal ausgeführt?
Wahrscheinlich steht das einfach,
der führt das einfach, die haben
eine Angabe, die blöd ist.
Haben die Bilderkennung dabei? Das glaube ich, nee,
das sind 84 Zeilen JavaScript, das war's.
Okay. Und das nutzt
keine Library, die danach aussieht.
Es sieht aus, ob die einfach eine Anzahl,
hier Ounces umrechnen oder so.
Ah, es benutzt Bluebird, sehr witzig.
Bluebird ist toll.
Wenn du aktuelles JavaScript schreiben willst, dann musst du
Bluebird benutzen, habe ich das Gefühl.
An Promises kommst du nicht mehr vorbei?
Oder wenn du bugfreie
Promises benutzen möchtest.
Oh Gott, verpackte Promise Libraries
kriegen ja nach der viel Debugging Spaß.
Also wir haben bloß neulich auf Arbeiten
einen Fall seziert, wenn du ein bisschen
hin und her sprichst zwischen
nativen Codes und
JavaScript
und das in eine Standard,
Wenn du einen Standard-Promise aus Node.js reinrappst,
dann kriegst du Fälle, wo dein Kurzfall läuft,
aber die Tests nicht bestehen.
Es gibt Standard-Promises?
Naja, ein Promise, was im modernen JavaScript ES6 drin ist.
Echt?
Ich habe ja meine wirkliche JavaScript-Zeit.
Das ist jetzt zwei Jahre her.
Es gibt Promises in JavaScript.
Das ist das Scheiß.
Promising Times.
Aber die wird es nicht mehr lange geben,
weil du async-await und dann schreibst du den gleichen asynchronen Code
und der sieht nicht mehr aus wie asynchroner Code.
Das ist aber schön. Async-Await habe ich mir nur mal in C-Sharp
angeschaut und da finde ich es tatsächlich echt hübsch.
Das hat im Endeffekt
die Auswirkung, dass du überall nur noch
Async
und Await überall davor schreibst
und dein Code dann einfach nicht mehr
aussieht wie funktionaler
Promise-Code, sondern einfach nur noch wie...
Aber will man es nicht gerade haben?
Weil gerade das Beschissene an solchen Codes
sieht kacke aus.
Du behandelst dann Fälle...
Du behandelst dann Fälle
wo dein Promise
fehlschlägt, plötzlich wie Exceptions
und schreibst wieder Try drumherum.
Das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen da anwidert.
Das finde ich gerade toll,
weil um jetzt wirklich den Language
Nerd Circle hier komplett zu ziehen.
Es hebt wieder die Sprache rein.
So ein Promise kannst du auch komplett
in der Library implementieren.
Async Await ist ein Sprachfeature.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Gerade in Swift haben wir das schöne Problem,
dass Apple halt ein
schönes Error-Modell mit reingebaut hat
was tatsächlich echt wunderschön ist,
aber du kannst es halt absolut überhaupt nicht für
asynchronen Kram nutzen, das geht einfach nicht.
In Swift gibt es Exceptions?
In Swift gibt es die heißen Errors
und die kannst du throwen und die kannst du catchen.
Also verhalten sie sich wie Exceptions?
Die sind essentiell Exceptions, wie in anderen Sprachen,
die heißen halt bloß Errors.
Die würden auch ein Level von mehreren Levels
überspringen oder so?
Die kannst du halt durchbubbeln, wenn du das meinst, wie du möchtest.
Also eine Funktion, die irgendwas ausführt,
was einen Error
throwt, der muss man
nicht ansehen. Doch, das haben
sie so gemacht. Du musst,
wenn du eine Funktion hast, die throwt kann,
dann musst du zumindest
try davor schreiben. Und wenn du das nicht machst,
dann hast du einen Compile Fehler. Genau.
Immerhin, das ist recht sauber, weil du kannst
nicht aus dem Weg gehen. Entweder kannst du,
wenn du try einfach so schreibst, weiter hochbubblen,
dann musst du die Funktion, wo du das aufbrust, auch throwen können.
Du kannst try-Fragezeichen hinschreiben, dann wird es
einfach ein Optional, dann kriegst du ein Result oder nicht,
wenn die throwt. Oder du machst ein try-Ausrufezeichen
und dann crasht es im Falle von einem Error.
das ist recht schön
das finde ich sprachlich und taktisch auch echt nett
aber du kannst es halt absolut überhaupt nicht
im asynchronen Code nutzen, weil du kannst
asynchron halt nichts werfen, überhaupt nicht
und das ist total bescheuert
dann finde ich, das ist angenehmer
wenn du halt irgendwie in der Standard-Lib
einen Result-Typ hättest, der macht dir das komplett weg
und gab es den nicht schon seit den ersten
Tagen von Swift irgendwie so eine Result-Library?
Es gibt eine Result-Library und es gibt
tatsächlich im Swift-Quelltext auch
ein Upcoming-Verzeichnis
Da ist ein Result auch drin.
Genau diesen Code kopiere ich mir in meiner Projekte mit rein,
damit ich meinen eigenen Result-Typ habe.
Aber das ist doch affig.
Also ich will Standard-Dripp einen Result-Typ haben,
der ordentlich funktioniert.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen so ein Taktik-Schucker draufwerfen.
Was passiert jetzt eigentlich mit Zwift?
Jetzt ist ja Chris Lettner irgendwie aus Apple raus.
Ja, aber er ist ja eh nicht der,
also er ist der, der die Sprache ins Leben gerufen hat.
Aber er ist ja nicht der, der aktiv hinter jeder Entscheidung steht.
Er ist kein benevolent Dictator.
Er ist jemand, der seine Ideen überall mit einfließen hat lassen
und aktiv natürlich mit daran gearbeitet hat.
Aber er ist einer in dem Team, die das gemacht haben.
Und dieses Team ist auch immer noch da.
Und er hat auch vollstes Vertrauen,
nicht so Merkel-mäßig, sondern ordentlich,
dass das halt gut weitergeführt wird.
Unser Publikum rollt sich gerade auf dem Fußboden.
Aber der wird auch weiterhin in der Community aktiv bleiben,
nicht bei Apple, halt bei Tesla.
Ja, stimmt.
Und er ist jetzt zu Tesla gegangen
und baut da jetzt irgendwie self-driving cars mit.
Genau.
Genau. Heißt das, dass die AI
auf den Teslas dann
ins Frucht geschrieben hat? Das ist in Podcast-Interviews
mit ihm mit angemunkelt worden, aber
das wäre
höchst unwahrscheinlich meiner Meinung nach
und er hat glaube ich auch irgendwas in die Richtung
gesagt, das ist einfach, das ergibt nicht
viel Sinn, das in die Richtung zu gehen.
Das wäre cool, aber ich bezweifle es.
Warum?
Das Witzige an dem
Swift-Code-Team ist halt, die setzen sich nicht
mit demselben Problem auseinander wie die Leute, die
Swift-Code schreiben. Die schreiben ja nur
Swift ist ja nicht self-hosted.
Und die rennen nicht in die Probleme,
die die Swift zur Image Show noch immer machen.
Und wenn die es merken würden,
dann wäre, glaube ich, Swift noch ein bisschen woanders.
Natürlich will ich nicht rumhaken, die haben Ahnung.
Eine der großen Sachen,
die eigentlich an Swift so ein Missstand sind.
Eigentlich müssen sich die Leute hinsetzen
und sagen, wir schreiben jetzt Swift
in Swift neu. Aber was bringt es denn?
Was ist das denn für ein großer Vorteil?
Zum einen
hast du dann die
Geschichten, dass du jahrelang nicht wieder nachweisen
hörst, dass du keinen Überwachungscode in deiner Software
hast, weil der Compiler ja in der Sprache
selber geschrieben ist. Wie ist die Geschichte?
Das war einfach für GCC, oder?
Jetzt bin ich schlecht
vorbereitet. Naja, wenn
du den Compiler brauchst,
um den Compiler zu bauen,
dann hast du ja tatsächlich so eine
Mutter-Kind-Geschichte, die sie sich fortsetzt. Es gibt
keinen anderen Code, der was damit zu tun hat.
Und das könnte den
Effekt haben, dass es irgendwann mal, also es könnte,
es gibt diese Verspörungstheorie, dass es zum
Beispiel bei GCC.
GCC ist in C, C++ geschrieben
und kopiert C, C++.
Und der GCC wird, ist egal, der GCC wird
mit GCC kopiliert. Es könnte
irgendwann vor 20 Jahren, als GCC rauskam,
meine Version von GCC gegeben haben,
eine, die den ersten GCC
gebaut hat, oder der erste Compiler, der den ersten
GCC gebaut hat, mit dem dann alle anderen gebaut wurden,
könnte dort Schadcode
eingeführt haben
und diesen Schadcode führt der Compiler
von sich in den nächsten Compiler mit ein
und damit in alle anderen Programme.
und du kannst es aber nicht wirklich nachweisen,
weil es in dem Compiler so drin ist
und jeder Code, den du kompilierst,
enthält den Code
und es gibt aber auch keinen anderen Compiler,
der den Compiler kompiliert.
Ich glaube, GCC ist großgeguckt dafür,
dass Leute dann wahrscheinlich diverses
die Compiling gerade noch mal drauf geworfen
und zumindest mal reinzuschauen.
Bestimmte Dinge würden auch auffallen.
Also bei dem Network-Course ganz vergessen.
Diese Geschichte ist wieder gar nicht.
Das ist absolut gefährlich.
Aber ich meine, rein theoretisch möglich ist es.
Gar keine Frage.
Also diese Geschichte ist gerade wieder gefährlich.
Ich glaube, wir reden zu sehr durcheinander.
Das ist nicht angenehm für den Hörer.
Ich müsste diese Geschichte,
das ist wieder sowas, wo ich das mal nachschauen müsste.
Bitte schreibt mir das mal in den Kommentaren.
Wie hieß denn diese Verschwörungstheorie,
dass Compiler, die self-hosted sind,
sich selbst mit Spy-Code spicken.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
gerade die Leute, die einen Compiler bauen,
sollten sich mit den Schwachstellen
des Compilers in der Sprache beschäftigen.
und es wäre dementsprechend nur konsequent,
wenn sie sich hinsetzen würden und ihre eigenen Sprache
den Compiler neu bauen würden, weil die sind diejenigen,
die diese Sprache bauen
und die schreiben den ganzen Tag Code in einer anderen Programmiersprache.
Das wäre schön, wenn die es machen würden,
aber für mich gibt es diesen großen Mehrwertfaktor nicht.
Du sagst doch selber, dass Swift ständig abstürzt.
Ja, es läuft halt nicht stabil, es läuft immer besser,
es läuft natürlich wunderschön
und persönlich wäre es für die ganzen Leute, die Swift schreiben,
auch super toll, wenn die in den Compiler-Code
reinschauen könnten und es natürlich viel besser verstehen können,
als wenn da Unmengen an C++
Source liegen. Ich habe tatsächlich
gestern Zwift untergeladen.
Den Compiler? Den Source vom
Compiler und mal gebaut.
Vier Stunden später war mein Rechner
damit fertig. What?
Hast du
ein Release-Bild gemacht?
Nee, einfach nur, ich wollte,
also ich weiß, ich muss mich nur damit auseinandersetzen.
Mein Plan war... Der baut LLVM
mit, ne? Natürlich.
Ich habe auch danach mich gewundert, wo der
LVM-Source plötzlich herkam, der in einem
ganz anderen Verzeichnis auf meinem Rechner lag.
Also ein Parent DIR, aber
das war witzig.
Wenn du ein Bildsystem hast, was
Artefakte produziert, die nicht in dem
Ordner liegen, wo du angefangen hast
zu bauen. Nee, das soll nicht sein.
Aber es hat mich auch stark schockiert, dass das Ding halt, wie gesagt,
vier Stunden, also
3,7 Stunden genau zu sein,
dafür gebraucht hat, um das zu
bauen. Ich wollte tatsächlich mal, wir hatten
im deutschen Swift-Slack
gewitzelt drüber,
dass es spaßig wäre,
diverse Keywords von Swift zu
übersetzen ins Deutsche, also aus If ein
Falls zu machen und so weiter.
Und ich wollte einfach mal durchschauen, wie witzig
und fucking umständlich das denn wäre.
Wie würde die Sprache dann heißen?
Schwalbe.
Du müsstest eigentlich nur
die Grammatik ändern, oder?
Das nur stelle ich mir halt,
ich stelle es mir einfach vor, aber es ist höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht mal andersweise so einfach.
je nachdem, mit welchen Tools die
Compiler-Bauer arbeiten, hast du irgendwo
eine Grammatik-Datei rumliegen.
Ja, und ich muss wahrscheinlich alle Tests,
die noch mit drin liegen, entweder entfernen, auskommentieren
und sonst wie, weil sonst geht der Bild nicht durch.
Ja, du solltest dann halt gleich Transpiler dafür bauen.
Es wäre cool, also ich würde mich
tierisch freuen, wenn ich auch nur ein Keyword
finde. Aber wenn du nur Keywords übersetzt,
dann könnte dein Transpiler tatsächlich
eine regular Expression sein.
Ich dachte mir auch, gehe ich es
einfacher an, gehe ich es schlimmer an?
Es wäre witzig, auf jeden Fall. Ich setze mich damit
auf jeden Fall noch auseinander und
das wäre cool, wenn ich da auch nur
an einer Stelle winzig keinen Erfolg hinbekomme.
Das ist das, worüber sich die Leute bei Rust
die ganze Zeit beschweren, dass Move
ein Keyword der Sprache ist.
Okay. Also wenn du damit ein Spiel machst,
kannst du damit keine Moves beschreiben.
Und witzigerweise, wenn du in den Compiler-Code
reinguckst, dann dürfen die halt
die ganzen Sachen, die so selbst-referencing
sind, hast du auch bei anderen
Compilern, siehst du, das dürfen sie halt nicht mit den gleichen Namen
benennen. Also wenn jetzt ein Stück
Compiler sich mit Klassen auseinandersetzt,
dann darf das Ding Class heißen.
Dann muss das Class mit K heißen.
Und die ganzen Types,
alles was sich auf Types bezieht, heißt im
Compiler TY.
Was natürlich auch wunderschön die Stellen zu finden ist.
Und so weiter und so fort.
In Swift kannst du es
zumindest umgehen, indem du Backticks drumherum packst.
Wenn ich eine Property von meinem Typen
Type nennen möchte, dann meckert mir der Compiler
oder ich nehme halt einfach Backticks drumherum und dann
kann ich es so nennen. Das finde ich sehr
angenehm.
Swift hat sehr viel mehr Syntax.
Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl, die reißen sich den Arsch auf,
eine viel größere Sprache zu bauen, als notwendig wäre.
Und das macht halt das ganze Ökosystem viel instabiler,
aber schöner zum Nutzen.
Also die wollen eine wunderschöne Sprache bauen.
Ich weiß immer nicht, ob es schön ist,
wenn man einfach eine komplexe Sprache macht
oder wenn man Sachen an einer Sprache macht.
Ich bin auch nicht so ein großer Freund von Operatoren.
Du kannst natürlich eigene Operatoren definieren.
und dafür gibt es
toll. Gab es nicht irgendwie
Badges für Gitterprepos,
wo sich Leute nämlich gerübt haben,
dass diese Library keine eigenen
Operatoren definiert? Ja, wollte ich bei mir auch mal
reinschmeißen, weil so eine Library sollte sowas
niemals tun. Finde ich schrecklich.
Ja, aber für Libraries ist das gedacht, wenn du einen Typen hast
und dann darauf eine Operation ausführen willst,
wo machst du sowas sonst?
Also für eine Executable, für eine App, was auch
immer, kann ich es gerne mehr einbauen, wenn ich
da zur Vereinfachung irgendwas brauche, wenn
ich der Endkonsument schon bin, aber ich
dass sowas in der Library ist.
Ich will nicht, wenn ich mir den Code reinziehe.
Wenn die Library das intern nutzt, gerne.
Haut das rein. Aber internal
Operators gehen in Swift, soweit ich weiß,
noch nicht. Ist geplant? Habe ich mal gelesen?
Internal Operators. Also so ein Private Operator
letztendlich.
Ist das halt witzig? Es ist ein witziges
Konzept, aber... Ich habe für die Vorbereitung dieser Sendung
noch ein bisschen Zeit investiert und
wollte...
Bei Methodisch Incorrect gibt es ja
Musik der Woche
und dann haben sie irgendwie
irgendwelche nerdigen Covers
von Popsongs,
die sich dann auf
Biologie, Chemie, Physik beziehen.
Ich hatte eine schöne Idee für was.
Vielleicht können wir das hin- und herschneiden.
Und zwar von Shade.
Move Operator.
Geil.
Gotta implement the move
operator.
Aber du machst das, ey. Du spielst das.
Da muss ich das ja auch singen.
Oh Gott, ich habe es gerade gesehen.
Kriegen wir mal live hin sogar.
Eine Live-Einlage von Hendrik Sollich.
Vielleicht spiele ich das ja beim 10-jährigen Jubiläum des ASCII.
Machen wir eine Aufnahme von?
Dann.
Ja.
So, das ist übrigens, das ASCII wird 10.
Krass.
Was so geil ist das ASCII?
Übrigens, die heutige Folge ist gesponsert vom ASCII.
Ich habe nämlich die Marte, die wir uns aus dem Kühlschrank geholt haben,
nicht bezahlt.
Gut, machen wir nachher noch, das wissen wir nicht so.
Vom ASCII und von
Kollemarte. Natürlich, Kollemarte,
unser langjähriger Sponsor, die wahrscheinlich
immer noch nichts davon wissen, dass sie uns in Folge
2 schon wieder sponsern.
Ich habe übrigens gerade
etwas davon, es gibt ja das sogenannte Herrengedeck.
Herrengedeck ist ein
Korn und ein Bier.
Ich bin für die Einführung des Begriffs
Nerdgedeck.
und das ist eine Mate und
eine Lakritzstange.
Du weißt nicht, ob die Lakritzstange so allgemein nerdig ist,
nur weil wir die gerne essen?
Wir sind jetzt nicht die Proto-Nerds.
Also ich werde nicht mein Skelett nach meinem Tod
freigeben für die Wissenschaft als die Definition eines Nerds.
Ach so.
Also zumindest nicht dafür.
Ich würde gerne mal...
Also ich bin in einer Signal-Gruppe,
die heißen Jazz-Nerds.
Da kommen dann immer so Konzert-Tipps rum.
gehen wir meistens in
Jazzgrip-Tonne und wenn wir da so in einer
Reihe sitzen, das sind so zwei
Typen vom
theoretischen Informatik-Lehrstuhl
und ich,
da so in einer Reihe sitzen, merke ich schon, dass
wir doch schon sehr prototypisch
aussehen.
Also aussehen vor allem.
Nicht die Themen,
über die ihr redet.
Nee, die reden über Baumsprachen
und sowas. Nee, das ist ja überhaupt nicht
Die einzigen Baumsprachen, die ich kenne, sind die, die auf Bäumen gesprochen werden.
Das ist am meisten U-Buch und Ack-Ack.
Aha.
Den wird es schneiden wir raus.
Ich weiß es noch, wenn ich mich mit Freunden zusammensetze,
und wir hatten mal ein Stichwort, ich weiß es leider nicht mehr,
dass wir genutzt haben, wenn wir plötzlich wieder über Kerning gesprochen haben
oder irgendwelche anderen kaputten Fontmerkmale
nicht nur über Fonds, über beliebiges,
nerdiges Fonds haben wir unser Go-To-Beispiel für
wir driften schon wieder ab.
Aber Fonds ist doch schon ein sehr hipster, nerdiges
Thema. Überhaupt nicht, das ist
voll tiefgründig und wichtig und überall mit
drin. Das stimmt tatsächlich, also
man kann in einer Firma zusammensitzen
mit einem Haufen professioneller
hochqualifizierter
Softwareentwickler und man unterhält sich über Schriftarten,
weil Schriftarten natürlich
dein Handwerkszeug sind.
Wenn du deinen
mit deinem Texteditor, mit einer richtigen, gut lesbaren
Schriftart und einem richtigen
Colorscheme einstellst, dann
optimierst du damit deinen Arbeitsalltag.
Auf jeden Fall. Und da steckt man auch Zeit rein
in diese Auswahl und
in den Wechsel davon und die
Vorbereitung.
Da ist schon unendlich viel Zeit mehr reingeflossen.
Also ich finde es immer wieder schön, wenn
professionelle Editoren
Liter,
oh Gott, jetzt fällt mir der Rekloff nicht ein,
Legaturen unterstützen.
Legaturen sind wichtig.
Nein, die sind nicht wichtig.
Doch, ich bin mich so dran gewöhnt.
Wenn du ein Ungleichzeichen hast,
das heißt, Ausrufezeichen ist gleich
und dein Editor macht so ein langes,
quer durchgestrichenes Istgleich durch.
Also es muss ja nicht wie zwei Zeichen aussehen.
Wenn du zum Beispiel
JavaScript schreibst,
ich habe gerade was von hochqualifizierten Softwaren,
wenn du zum Beispiel
JavaScript schreibst und du hast drei ist gleich,
weil du musst ja ein JavaScript leider
3 istgleich schreiben, weil das
sonst nur ein Fuzzy ist, gleich ist.
Dann macht er dir ein istgleich mit 3 Strichen draus.
Ich mag
Ligatur-Support. Also ich nutze sehr gerne Fonts wie
4er-Code, die sowas mit
populär gemacht haben. Ich hätte gerne sogar
noch Schriftarten. Also
falls sowas irgendjemand macht, falls irgendjemand
diesen Podcast hört.
Ich hätte gerne Schriftarten. Es gibt ja
4er-Codes, wolltest du gerade erzählen, die gerade so
Operatoren sexy machen. Ich hätte gerne
Varianten von 4er-Code für unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen,
wo die Keywords zu Symbolen werden.
Wo du aus einem If ein Zeichen machst
oder aus einem Else ein Zeichen.
Das gefällt mir.
Dann entsteht zwischen dem If und dem Else
eine Struktur, die dann das abkapselt,
dein Block.
Ihr solltet Hendricks Handbewegung gerade sehen können,
wie er sich diese Strukturen vorstellt
und kapselt und zusammenschiebt.
Du musst noch ein bisschen vor dem Mikrofon wedeln,
damit der Zuhörer merkt,
wie ich die Hände bewege.
Das wäre schon stark.
Auf jeden Fall geht es um Emoji-Code.
Diese Sprache, die alle Keywords als einzelne Emojis
definiert. Das ist so ein kleines Box
oben für Package-Imports und
das ist großartig.
Das ist nur gerade nicht.
Aber klar, ich habe quasi
genau das gerade beschrieben. Ne, das ist das Gegenteil davon.
Also wenn ich Emoji-Code schreiben würde,
dann würde ich das in einer
Compile-to-Emoji-Code-Sprache machen
und würde tatsächliche Wörter schreiben,
die ich tippen kann.
Und da würde ein Emoji-Code draus kompiliert werden,
den dann kein Mensch wieder schreiben kann
ohne eine Emoji-Taste tun.
Aber was geiler wäre,
wenn du zum Beispiel das Import zu Ende schreibst
und dann dein Editor,
weil die Font das so beschreibt,
nachdem du das T fertig geschrieben hast,
aus dem Import so eine Kiste macht oder sowas.
Das wäre cool.
Es gibt doch diese Bullshit-Font.
Ich wollte gerade sagen Bullshit-Sans, genau.
Das ist mir nicht der Einwurf gewesen.
Du musst aufpassen, wenn du auch so sehr Bullshit in deinen Bewerbungsunterlagen stehen hast,
weil du das noch irgendwie vor drei Jahren mal installiert hattest und dann vergessen hast.
Du hast die PDF rausgewendet und mit Embedded Fonts oder was?
Ich glaube, PDFs sind immer mit Embedded Fonts.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist sie nicht.
Oh mein Gott, da habe ich schon so viel Spaß mitgehabt.
Ja, Bullshit-Sons, diese wunderschöne Fonts, die diverse Buzzwords wie Synergie oder so ähnlich
halt durch ein Bullshit-Label ersetzt
und ist einfach toll.
Großartig, wenn man die Präsentation hat und der Firmenname ist
Bullshit. Bullshit und hinten noch
so irgendwie C-Y-Z-Lon, keine Ahnung.
Bullshit-D-Ink.
Bullshit-Welchen.
Es gibt auch so Firmennamen, ich kenne
mindestens zwei oder drei, die heißen irgendwie,
ich möchte jetzt die Firmen nicht dissen, aber die heißen
Inno-Irgendwas.
Und dann so wie Innovation und dann
aber irgendein anderes Wort, keine Ahnung.
Inno Spire
oder Inno
Available oder so. Das waren tatsächlich
die Firmennamen. Entschuldigung, also ich weiß
von diesen Firmen nichts und ich wollte es so nicht dissen, aber ich finde
die Namensgebung ist so ein bisschen
innovativ. Sehr innovativ.
Also da wollte wirklich jemand
die Nachricht und die Message
unterstreichen, dass er innovativ ist,
indem man sich den Namen Inno irgendwie
mit reinbaut.
Jo, wollen wir mal noch
zwei Fuck-Ups oder drei Fuck-Ups, je nachdem
wie viele wir zusammenkriegen.
mit ansprechen, weil da haben
lustiger Kram in den letzten Wochen passiert.
Also wir, es war
eine gute Idee von Google
vor einem Jahr
anzufangen, aus dem Browser den Support
für SHA-1 rauszukicken.
Oh ja. Oder das
langsam zu deprecaten, weil
jetzt ist es gebrochen.
Aber ich meine,
also die haben die erste Collision mit
PDFs hinbekommen oder irgendwas war da.
Die Aussage war,
man kann die Technik benutzen, um halt weitere Collisions
damit herzustellen. Und es gibt jetzt, ich sehe jetzt immer wieder
Skripte, dieses Skript,
dieses ist ein animiertes GIF,
das zeigt
sein eigenes,
seinen eigenen SHA-1-Hash an.
Das gab es aber noch nicht. Also für MD5 habe ich es gesehen,
für SHA-1 und nicht. Dieses ist ein Skript,
das produziert
seinen eigenen SHA-1
und MD5-Hash
und es ist gleich.
Das ist wunderschön, so war es toll.
Also am schlimmsten fand ich eigentlich,
Also für die Leute, die bis jetzt durchgehalten haben
und trotzdem nicht wissen, was SHA-1 und MD5 sind,
das sind Hash-Algorithmen.
Um es kurz zu sagen, ein Hash-Algorithmus ist ein Algorithmus,
der aus einer beliebigen Menge Daten eine feste Länge
zufällig aussehende Zahlenstruktur macht,
die dadurch vergleichbar ist
und eine Aussage über die Echtheit eines Dokuments machen kann,
wenn ich etwas runterlade.
Und mir wird gesagt, wenn ich das runtergeladen habe,
werde ich diese SHA-1 oder MD5-Summe daraus generieren können
und ich kann das, dann hat sich
von der Übertragung bis zu mir
an dem Dokument nichts verändert.
Das ist super, um
E-Mail zu signieren. Es sei denn, man
verwendet
ein Verfahren, was gebrochen ist und gebrochen
heißt, dass jemand, der es angreift,
eine beliebige
Summe erzeugen kann,
obwohl er den Inhalt verändert hat.
Und das ist jetzt mit SHA-1 möglich.
Mit MD5 schon lange?
Mit MD5 schon lange. Wie gesagt, schön fand ich die Aussage,
dann können wir uns ja jetzt die ganze Rechenzeit
und den ganzen Strom sparen
und das viel effizientere MD5
wieder nehmen, ohne
großartig an Sicherheit zu verlieren.
Supergeil.
Also,
SHA-1 ist tot, lang lebe MD5.
Oh Gott.
MD5 ist ja auch wirklich
reichend, um sich eine Linux-DVD runterzuladen
und zu schauen, dass die nicht kaputt gegangen ist.
Ich könnte natürlich wirklich
Malware damit untergemuggelt.
Kennst du BosoCrack? Nein.
Das ist ein Ruby-Gem, mit dem kannst du MD5 cracken.
Aber ich fand die Implementierung so großartig.
Was der macht, ist, du gibst ihm einen Hash
und der versucht rauszufinden, was der gehashte String ist
oder was auch immer eben reinkam, um den Hash zu generieren.
Und wie der das macht, ist, der Google einfach den Hash
und nimmt den ersten Google-Treffer und gibt dir den aus.
Und das stimmt halt in 90% der Fälle.
Also dafür muss es ja nicht gebrochen sein.
Nee, nee, dafür muss ich gebrochen sein.
Aber es gibt halt so viele Veröffentlichungen von Ragotables
und sonstigen Kram, wo einfach das schon da steht
und Google hat das komplett indiziert, aber ich fand das einfach
so geil, bozo-quack, wie ist das geschrieben, das ist
10 Zeilen Ruby, what the fuck, ach der googelt das einfach.
Fand ich geil.
Großartig.
Ja, so schnell brichst du
so schnell brichst du an D5.
Nee, aber
was genau hat Google...
Das ist doch eigentlich eine Leistung.
Das wollte ich da auch nicht reinschieben, aber
ich sprich mir doch das erstmal anwört. Was hat Google jetzt genau gemacht?
Die haben SHA-1 gebrochen aktiv.
Aber das gibt ja, ich bin ja jetzt
kein Experte, es gibt ja
in den Hacker-News-Kommentaren
da irgendwie gibt es drei verschiedene Angriffe
und das war jetzt nur einer von denen, die noch
nicht so relevant sind, um damit Angriffe zu fahren,
aber zeigen, dass es eben kaputt
als herrschenden Algorithmus ist.
Irgendwie sowas. Weißt du
da mehr? Ich würde das mal lesen.
Dann gehen wir da jetzt mal
nicht allzu tief drauf ein. Witzig
ist bloß, dass viele Leute eben mit gesagt haben,
dass Git ja auch
SHA-1-Hashes nutzt und Git auch jetzt total
vulnerable ist, was ich nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Git nutzt zwar SHA-1,
aber das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, dass
ein Angreifer auf meinen Remote irgendwie draufkommt
die Authentication, dafür läuft der völlig
daran vorbei, der kann ja nichts
da hinschieben, wenn ich keine Ahnung
GitHub Nutzer als Remote und... Ne, aber du kannst
jetzt Commits generieren, die
sich verändert haben
und die aber den gleichen Commit Hash
wie andere Commits haben und dementsprechend kannst
du die in eine komplette Entwicklungshistory
von einem Git Repo
irgendwo mittendrin reinschreiben und das
gesamte... Aber da brauche ich trotzdem als Angreifer schon
Zugang irgendwie.
Ja, das ist vorausgesetzt.
Aber du kannst jetzt
einzelne Commits, wenn du das hinkriegst,
einzelne Commits in der
History von einem
Repo austauschen.
Und den Leuten Code unter mogeln.
Ja, das kriegt auch keiner mit, wer
schaut denn seine History so durch regelmäßig an.
Und mein Kind selber würde
das ja nicht markieren als fraudulent
sonst was, sondern hey, ja, der Baum
sieht super aus.
Okay, das ist
recht valide.
Aber bei Git kann man den
Hash-Algorithmus ja auch austauschen.
Halt nicht rückwirkend,
aber... Das ist halt die Frage, wie gut
sowas geht, da hat sich
Dinos Torvalds ja auch schon zu geäußert
auf Mailinglisten, aber
da habe ich mich auch nicht so auseinandergesetzt.
Es ist so einfach, wie ich es gerade beschrieben habe, ist es nicht,
weil die Hashes
basieren natürlich immer auch auf der
auf den Dateien,
auf allen Dateien und
ein Commit-Hash basiert,
nicht nur einfach den vorherigen Commit-Hash,
sondern jeder Commit-Hash nimmt den gesamten Dateiinhalt
des Repos.
Das heißt, du müsstest das für jeden darauf folgenden Commit auch machen.
Ich dachte, die Hashtag-Mondell aktuell entschädigt.
Das erklärt auch, warum ein Commit in der Facebook-Code-Basis 20 Minuten dauert.
Die haben so komische Super-Bilds.
Du meinst so Monorepos?
Monorepos.
Facebook und Google sind so die beiden Kandidaten,
die komplett alles an Produkten, was sie haben,
in einem Repo liegen haben.
So, an dieser Stelle
meldet sich eine Stimme aus dem Off.
Und zwar haben wir einen Gast heute eingeladen.
Eigentlich müsste man die Gäste ganz am Anfang vorstellen,
aber plötzlich betritt Steiger den Raum.
Hallo Steiger.
Hey.
Du möchtest uns korrigieren.
Ja, mir ist diese Diskussion auf Hacker News auch aufgefallen,
in der sich Jemus geäußert hat.
Und wo es um die SHA-1-Hashes in Git geht.
Und dort wurde ein Verfahren skizziert,
wie man das austauschen könnte.
Und das Problem ist ja dann immer noch,
wenn man dem Git Daten unterjubelt,
die es nicht auseinanderhalten kann,
weil der SHA-1-Hash identisch ist,
dann muss es das ja auch noch verteilen.
Das könnte ich ja nur noch mit einem Force-Push zum Beispiel erzwingen.
Aber wenn ich das quasi nicht auf das zentrale Repo,
wo es das zentrale Repo bei Git.
Wenn ich es dort nicht hinbekomme, dann verteilt sich das ja nicht weiter.
Ja, aber du könntest einen Angriff skizzieren,
wo du dich bei jemandem in eine Verbindung injectest,
dass du zum Beispiel, ich pulle mir jetzt oder ich klone mir ein Repo-Initial von GitHub,
dann hat irgendjemand in meinem System andere Keys untergemogelt
und ich verbinde mich nicht direkt mit GitHub, sondern werde gemandelt
gemittelt und klone mir dann ein Repo
oder pulle auf ein Repo
drauf, was ich schon habe,
neue Commits, wo
dann plötzlich Schadcode drin ist und ich merke es
nicht, weil ich mir
ein funktionierendes Repo geklont habe,
was eventuell hinterher sogar,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich danach von dem
Original nochmal drauf klonen können müsste,
aber auf die Art und Weise könntest du das machen.
Du kannst es natürlich nicht einfach so hochladen.
Es könnte natürlich irgendeiner morgen bei GitHub
einbrechen und den Linux-Körnel, der
nicht von GitHub verteilt wird, aber
in irgendwelche populären
Softwareprojekte Code
injecten auf die Art und Weise. Ja, also da gibt es
auf jeden Fall noch viel mehr Projekte
und das praktische
Resümee dieser Diskussion, zumindest
wie es mir aufgefallen war,
ist, dass man ja
dem Entwickler einfach ein bisschen
Geld zuschanzen könnte und der implementiert
einfach dieses Backdoor in dem Code
und pusht ihn regulär, als dass man
mehrere tausend CPU-Stunden
darauf verwendet, irgendwie
den Code dort reinzuschmuggeln.
Das könnte die Familie des Entwicklers
entführen. Halt mir praktisch fest,
das geht auf klassische Angriffsmöglichkeiten.
Also Angriffe sind technisch gesehen
möglich, aber würden
sich nicht in dem Maße lohnen, wie einfach mit einer
dem XKCD Beispiel
folgen, mit einer Brechstange hinter dem Entwickler zu stehen,
dem anzudrohen, ihm einen
über den Schädel zu ziehen, wenn er nicht jetzt hier den
Scheiß macht.
Ich mache dir ein Angebot, was du nicht erblenden kannst.
Entweder kommen
die Tastatur.
So als Briefe schreiben.
Ja, also was machen wir dagegen?
Man kann bei Git übrigens seine Commits auch signieren.
Das mache ich immer.
Signiert das, macht das
einen eigenen Hash über den Code?
Oder signiert das nur den Hash,
den es schon gibt? Das weiß ich nicht.
Das kann ich dir leider nicht sagen.
Wenn du nur den Code, den
Hash signiert,
den es schon gibt, dann hast du nichts gewonnen davon.
Bestimmt. Ich habe mir
angewöhnt, meine Commits immer zu signieren. Also nicht
Sign-off-Feature zu nutzen, den keine Sache nutzt,
außerhalb vom Linux-Körner, sondern
Commits zu signieren.
Musst du dann jedes Mal deinen Passphrase eingeben?
Der wird persistiert,
frag mich nicht wo. Ich hoffe, in meiner Keychain
oder im sonstigen
weitigen Credential Manager. Auf jeden Fall muss ich
die nicht jedes Mal eingeben, aber
in einer Organisation, in der ich auf GitHub
tätig bin, slash war,
wurde es mal das wahrsenshalber, ich meine,
du kannst ja als Committer angeben,
warum du möchtest, einfach mal den Namen von dem anders,
E-Mail-Adresse von dem anders, von der du weißt,
dass die auf GitHub bei dem anderen hinterlegt ist
und du pusht die Chain, es sieht halt so aus, ob der andere hier
irgendwelchen Spaß committed hat.
GitHub identifiziert dich
nur anhand deiner E-Mail-Adresse
und des Namens, der in deiner Kontrolle steht.
Genau, und GitHub macht halt dann, matcht die E-Mail-Adresse
auf das Benutzerkonto.
Du kannst halt dann direkt mit dem zu tun, dass
dieser GitHub-User woanders
irgendwas Spaß committed hat.
Wenn du gemeinsam mit Leuten an Projekten arbeitest
und nicht weißt, wer von den
fünf Kollegen da diesen Commit gemacht hat,
weil die ihre Git-Config nicht richtig gemacht haben,
oder halt von 10 verschiedenen
Rechner-Coden und auf einem halt
verkackt haben und da halt sonst wie
Rechner-Name.local steht statt einer E-Mail-Adresse.
Oder von 3 unterschiedlichen
Rechnern committen und auf jedem
jemand anders sind, weil sie überall subtil
eine andere E-Mail-Adresse haben.
Das nervt unheimlich.
Also ich, ach nee.
5 Autoren, hä, hab ich nur so 2 Leute dran tätig?
Ja, genau.
Ich hab jetzt meinen GPG-Key
mal aktualisiert.
Ich hab den noch nicht, meinen alten noch nicht
revoked. Hast du das Revocation
Zertifikat oder hast du den Private Key noch von Malten?
Ja, ja, ja.
Was mich echt an
kurz an GPG ist, dass es so scheiße
unpraktisch ist. Also
du musst googeln, um herauszufinden, wie du dein Key,
wie du so ein Zertifikat erzeugst.
Du musst dann
auf unterschiedliche
verteilen sich
Keychain, tauschen sich
diese Key-Server alle untereinander aus.
Hoffentlich, aber die meisten auf jeden Fall.
Bei allen sicher nicht, aber die meisten.
Ja, und dann
habe ich geschaut, ob ich mich jetzt komplett
Keybase-IO hingebe.
Bitte nicht dein Private Key dort hochladen.
Nee, aber der Client
ist mittlerweile auch
ein
PGP-Key-Verwaltungstool
geworden. Das heißt, du gibst dem
deinen Private Key
zur Verwaltung und signierst dann mit dem
Tool und es benutzt nicht die
original GenuPG-Toolchain
auf deinem Rechner mehr.
Ich bin, glaube ich, zum Hartraufen gekommen,
dass ich dir nicht beibringen konnte.
Da hat man meinen neuen,
veröffentliche man meinen neuen PubKey.
Übrigens, hier ist nur der PubKey.
Nimm nur den PubKey.
Veröffentliche bitte meinen PubKey.
Das war's.
Ich möchte hier mit dem Feld, wo ich es reinpacen kann.
Das ist alles.
Dankeschön.
Nee, macht er nicht.
Der nimmt das jetzt, das Tool möchte das annehmen und verwalten.
Der möchte, dass du den freistellst.
Der möchte, dass das Tool dein Private Key verwalten dürfen.
Dann lädst du nur deinen PubKey hoch.
Aber dann musstest du dem Tool irgendwann mal
deinen Private Key so geben.
Und da kriegst du schon so ein bisschen
Zähneknirschen, wenn du das machst.
Ich war kurz davor,
ich habe dann auf Twitter gepostet,
also es war ein
trumpianischer
Rage-Post von mir.
Was habe ich
da gemacht? Ich schäme mich so ein bisschen dafür.
Ist Keybase.io still relevant
today?
Ich habe gleich die Antwort bekommen, ja.
Die werden langsam relevant, ja.
Aber die haben ja auch coole Features,
aber das ging mir so ein bisschen auf den Keks.
Also ich hätte gerne das, ich habe es ja auch eine Weile nicht benutzt,
das alte Tool, was ich von denen hatte,
die wurde nicht mehr akzeptiert, dann musste ich mir das neue Tool installieren.
Um meinen Key zu aktualisieren,
muss ich dem Tool kurzzeitig
meinen Piped Key geben.
Okay, das ist weird.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin ganz glücklich mit den GPG-Tools, die es für Mac gibt.
Ich nutze ausschließlich die GUI darüber
für GPG-Dinge.
Die kann auch alles, was ich haben möchte,
die kann signieren.
Das basiert auf der Toolchain.
auf jeden Fall. Und die
sind da auch recht aktiv dahinter. Immer wenn ein neues
macOS rauskommt, muss man immer ein paar Wochen warten,
bis das wieder sich in Mail-App
integriert hat. Aber ansonsten ist
es echt super Zeug von klasse Leuten.
Aber ich bin auch sehr glücklich mit Keybase, muss ich sagen.
Also die CRI nutze ich
selten, also so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Wie ist mittlerweile ein Go
beschrieben? Ja, das ist schon eine Weile. Aber das machen
irgendwie alle, die sich von irgendwas von sich halten. Ich weiß nicht,
wieso. Wahrscheinlich, weil es
Cost Compiling einfach so einfach ist.
Go ist in der Stelle einfacher zu deployen, als
Wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich der Deployment-Schritt,
der da stark hilft.
Das ist ja geil.
Keybase hat ja coole Features,
in seinem Neuesten Moment zugefügt,
in zum einen dieses File-System
und zum anderen Chat,
den die jetzt in ihren leider elektron-basierten Desktop-Client
mit reinschmeißen.
Und Steiger zeigt mir gerade,
das dachte man selber.
Ich habe mir einfach mal fix einen Account geklickt,
weil ich es noch nicht kannte bisher.
Log mich dort ein und das Erste, was es sagt,
hey, das sind Files von Woody,
die warten auf dich.
Und dann denke ich mir so, woher weiß
dieses System, dass ich
weiß, wo die bekommen sollen?
Du kannst, also du
nutzt dieses Ding,
um deine unterschiedlichen Accounts,
die du im Internet hast, damit zu verifizieren.
Also da steht dann auf deiner Seite, dass du
dein GitHub-Account verifiziert hast
und dein Twitter-Account, weil du irgendwann mal
ein Private Key gesignetes
Stück Text auf Twitter
oder auf GitHub hochgeladen hast.
Und das Coole ist, auf die Art und Weise kannst du
auf Keybase.io Leute finden,
anhand ihres GitHub- oder Twitter-Accounts
und dann mit denen chatten.
Und das Einzige, was du wissen musst von dem anderen,
ist seine GitHub-ID.
Cool. Das ist echt praktisch.
Und vor allem kannst du halt mit den Internetfreunden,
die du nicht im echten Leben kennst,
wenn ich ihm auf Twitter folge.
Ich kann eben verifizieren,
einerseits, wenn ich weiß, dass der Account ihm gehört,
dass unter anderem auch dieser GitHub-Account dem gehört
und diese Webseite dem gehört.
Da kann ich mir dann sicher sein,
solange das natürlich nicht irgendwie von einem Angreifer
mit Access zu seiner Machine sonst wie komponentiert wurde.
kann ich mir jedenfalls da sicher sein, kann
verschlüsselte Nachrichten an diese Person schicken und kann mir über
dieses coole Keybase File System aktuell sogar
auch das einscharen. Das File System
ist irgendwie das krasseste Ding. Ja, ich weiß
auch immer noch nicht genau, wie das läuft, aber es ist
cool. Es ist ein Stückchen
mit
GPG, verschlüsseltes
Stück AVS
Ja, es läuft sicherlich mit dem S3-Bucket
irgendwo zusammen. Ja.
Aber es ist witzig und vor allem, wie ich stärker gerade
gemerkt habe, kriegst du ja auch, wenn du dich da anmeldest,
Hey, du hast Nachrichten.
Ich habe, glaube ich, immer mal damit rumgespielt,
weil ich fest davon ausgehe, dass du schon bei Keybase.io bist.
Okay.
Vermute mal, das wird Fuse sein bei dem Fallsystem.
Ja, ja, bestimmt.
Das ist ein Fuse-Fallsystem.
Was hinten dran hängt, ist die Frage.
Ich weiß nicht, war es letzte Woche noch da?
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Der AWS-Fack-Up steht tatsächlich in meiner Liste.
Für der Fack-Up.
Was war da passiert? Ich habe das neulich gehört.
Das Geiste war halt...
Da wollte jemand ein bisschen sparen und rumskalieren
und hat dann zu viel runterskaliert.
Die hatten Probleme in dem Billingsystem
und wollten das debuggen
und drei, vier Server offline nehmen
und haben halt aus Versehen
ein paar mehr Server offline genommen
und letztendlich waren es dann sehr, sehr viele Server
und S3 war dann halt
down, vier, fünf Stunden lang
und witzig war halt auch
vor allem, dass in der UK gerade irgendwie so eine
AWS Availability Party lief und
währenddessen haben die es halt total
verkackt. Das fand ich mega geil.
Aber das Beste daran,
mit Abstand das Beste, ist halt
die AWS-Status-Page. Hat halt die
ganze Zeit angezeigt, hey, grün, alle Systeme
laufen super, weil das Icon
für das rote Icon auf
S3 gehostet ist. Und wenn
du halt eine Status-Page baust
und die halt den Status von dem Service
anzeigt, dann darf sie doch verdammt nochmal nicht auf
diesen fucking Service laufen. Das ist doch einfach nur
bescheuert. Das heißt,
jeder hat dieses grüne Icon aus dem
Cache geladen? Die Leute haben halt diese
Status-Page angeschaut, die Status-Page behauptet halt die ganze Zeit,
ja, alle Services super und
3 läuft perfekt. Und ihr wollt die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund
dieses rote Bildchen laden und habt es nicht geschafft?
Ich weiß jetzt nur, was rote Bildchen war oder halt die
JSON, die der reinzieht, um das Ziel.
Die Statusseite müsstest du über
Akamai ausliefern oder
über irgendeinen anderen CDN. Da steht dann
drin, alles ist tot.
Und das Fittensstück Skript aus,
was von S3 geladen wird
und das schreibt dann rein, alles ist super.
Und wenn das Skript nicht geladen werden kann, dann funktioniert es.
Genau, so soll das gemacht sein.
Das erinnert mich an einer Zeit, wo das
Stratu tatsächlich mal passiert ist.
und dann fiel auf, also vor sehr langer Zeit,
als der Fachschaftsrat der Informatikfakultät in Dresden
auch seinen Webspace bei Strato hatte.
Das ist echt lang her.
War da auf jeden Fall weg.
Die Streubusseite war aber da.
Also der Hostel war noch profitbar
und es kam raus, dass der Hostel selbst seine Hostel
nicht bei sich hostet.
War auf jeden Fall witzig.
Okay, spaßig.
Aber ich meine, so willst du die eigentlich machen, zumindest für eine Status-Page.
Die Status-Page läuft im besten Fall bei deinem Competitor, bei deinem Konkurrenten,
auf dem Seite der Infrastruktur.
Und dann ist sie völlig abgekapselt von dem, was du machst.
Darauf sollte die nicht laufen, wenn die die Status davon monitoren.
Solange dein Competitor abstürzt und dein Zeugs weiterläuft,
möchte ja auch keiner deine Status-Page sehen.
Wenn deine Status-Page abschmiert, sei es drum.
Die Status-Page nutzt ja niemand aktiv als Infrastruktur.
Aber die sollte halt sehr reliable anzeigen können, wenn dein Scheiß nicht läuft.
Ich glaube, Amazon hat so ein bisschen das Problem, dass die so viel Zeugs machen, dass die halt auch nur ihr eigenes Zeugs verwenden wollen.
Aber die Dogfood.
Dogfood, ja.
Die Dogfood ohne Ende.
Ja.
Aber so eine Status-Page, die sollte auch irgendwie so wenig Services wie möglich anziehen.
Also sie sollte versuchen irgendwie auch, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht sehr effizient, aber die ganzen Bilder, die angezeigt werden,
Wir sollten mit als Base64
codiertes PNG in das
Detail-Spec-Standard.
Das rote Bild mit rein codiert ins HTML
und das grüne Bild lädst du dir dann von deinem
lokalen Datencenter.
Das wäre viel cleverer.
Wie gesagt, Deadman-Switch so ein bisschen drauf machen.
Es gibt irgendwie einen Hack, dass du
Ladebalken in GIFs
anzeigen kannst, indem du
das GIF so codierst,
dass du
machst so einen Dauerladen, das GIF
tatsächlich. Du lädst
runter, was eine unbestimmte
Größe hat, dann lädt das Ding immer weiter runter
und deine Gegenseite produziert
das GIF in dem Moment erst
und kann dir damit live eine Ladeanimation
schicken. Kennst du GIF-Sockets?
Das ist genau das,
bloß halt als Websocket
für uralte Clients, die sowas nicht können
und nutzt halt einfach GIF
als Datenpipeline.
Das ist total geil.
Man kann irgendwie mit HTML5
für ganz alte
Clients, die halt keine Websockets können.
Wie lesen die dann die Daten da raus?
Das rappt halt irgendwie die Library wieder weg
und dekodiert das.
Ich frage mich nicht, musst du dir anschauen.
Mir ist das, glaube ich, eingefallen. Es gibt so ein Projekt, das nennt sich GIFSocket.
Macht genau das.
Du kannst irgendwie Skripte in JavaScript
in Bilder kodieren und dann
mit dem Image-Tag oder
mit dem Canvas-Tag rauslesen, Pixel für Pixel.
Ja, da viel Grüße an Johannes
Kliemann, der hat da mal eine witzige Library geschrieben.
JavaScript in Bilder packen
und du embeddest das Bild in deine Seite und das JavaScript
gleich mit im Bild, ohne dass du halt aktiv
JavaScript embeddest, was halt auch
Angriffspunkt für diversen Spaß eben
bietet. Du musst aber trotzdem ein Stück Script
zum Laden des anderen Scripts aus dem Bild
mit einbetteln, oder? Da
muss ich tatsächlich wieder passen.
Das tut mir leid, dass ich da jetzt nicht
so in diese random einwürfe.
Ich glaube, den Satz von dir schneiden wir einfach raus,
dann wirkt es viel so vor, erinnern.
Image.js. Package
JavaScript to
Valid Image File.
Woran ist denn das geschrieben? C.
Ach, deswegen diese schwarze Zeile.
Ja, das Java wäre es doch kackbraun.
Genau, du kannst
XSS-Vunerabilities
eben exploiten, indem du einfach so ein Bild
auf eine Seite einbindest und in dem Bild ist halt
JavaScript drin. Ich weiß eigentlich nicht.
Genau, if you are able to put a script tag
on a website but can't run the script
because it only runs scripts from this website,
you can just upload, for example, a profile picture
containing the code you want to run.
Und wer führt das dann aus?
Anscheinend der Browser, der das
Bild darstellt.
Ja, aber du musst auch
ein Stück Skript haben, was die
Pixel wieder zu JavaScript dekodiert,
oder? Ich habe die Frage, musst du das?
Ist das irgendwie im Bildwanderer mit drin?
Das ist es, du kennst irgendwelche Lücken
im Decoder von
dem Browser.
Ist halt auch stark
formatabhängig. Es ist ja auch so geil, wenn du
auf diversen Plattformen, sei es
Plattformen, wo ich damals noch, also nicht an Explos
beteiligt war, aber zumindest die Explos mitbekommen habe, weil ich
die Plattform früh nutzte,
iOS oder die PSP oder sonst was,
die ersten Exploits sind immer
TIF-basiert, weil TIF halt so ein kaputtes Bildformat ist,
wo du beliebigen Code reinkloppen kannst,
der halt ausgeführt wird, wenn du das TIF anzeigen möchtest
und das berücksichtigt
halt niemand am Anfang. Die ersten iOS-Jailworks
waren TIF-Exploits. Die ersten
Exploits, um eine PSP
zu, wie hieß das, um Homebrew
auf den auszuführen, wie das damals hieß, waren
TIF-basiert. Das war für Custom-Firmers.
Großartig, geiler Scheiß. Immer TIFs.
Die ersten Exploits laufen immer über TIFs,
habe ich das Gefühl. Das finde ich geil.
Wenn nicht darüber, dann über PDFs.
PDF ist auch so ein kaputtes Format.
Es gibt einen schönen Talk
auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress
vor einigen Jahren,
der hieß
PDF, OMG, WTF.
Kann man mir denken,
um was es geht in dem Talk.
Ja, dass man mit PDF
wesentlich mehr machen kann,
als man sollte und als man denkt.
Also Vorsicht, wenn ihr...
Du kannst Videos embedden in PDFs.
Du kannst Skripte embedden in PDFs.
Alles machen.
Ich habe keine Mail bekommen. Steiger on Twitter.
In Klammern your friend. Just assign their
Keybase-Account irgendwas.
Ja, muss ich dir gleich mal follow.
Wir haben die ersten Leute schon überzeugt.
Ich muss meinen neuen Key noch hochladen.
Mach das, mach das.
Und ich muss meinen alten Key noch revoken. Das ist eigentlich das Ekligste daran.
Meinen alten Key revoken müssen.
Ich habe einen Freund von mir.
Viele Grüße. Ich nenne dich in diesem Kontext
mal nicht. In anderen Kontext
gerne, ich will nicht in die Public-Chair-Betreiben
aus Versehen, hatte
den Spaß, dass er einen
PHP-Key sich vor Ewigkeiten
generiert hat und wenn man das das erste Mal
macht, dann denkt man sich halt, der kann auslaufen,
das ist doch scheiße, will ich nicht auslaufen lassen.
Der läuft halt, der ist für immer valid
und hat dann irgendwann halt den Private-Key
verloren. Und jetzt flattert halt dieser
eine Key, der für immer gültig ist, der eben
einst mal gehörte in der Öffentlichkeit herum
und man kann halt nichts mehr tun, um den
weg loszuwerden. Was ist denn deine Einstellung?
Ablaufende Keys? Auf jeden Fall.
So bestenfalls jährlich.
Und dann halt nur wieder verlängern.
So wie es ist, dass du den noch besitzt.
Müsst du deine ganzen alten E-Mails irgendwie noch umcodieren?
Bleiben wir bei dir an deinem E-Mail-Account.
Wenn das ja selbe Key bleibt, dann ändert das doch nichts dran, oder?
Wie derselbe Key?
Wenn ich das Exploration-Date ändere, wird das ja kein neuer Key dadurch.
Ich signiere bloß den Key wieder irgendwie mit meinem privaten Counterpart
und lade den wieder auf den Key-Server hoch mit dem neuen Exploration-Date.
Achso, du änderst einfach vom gleichen Key?
Ich ändere, ich generell nicht ständig neue Private Keys.
Ich ändere einfach den...
Was ist davon der Mehrwert?
Dass ich eben halt immer wieder neu verifiziere,
dass das mein Key ist und dass der eben,
wenn ich halt den Private Key nicht mehr habe,
von selber abläuft und nicht mehr gültig ist.
Achso.
Tut mir leid, wenn das jetzt nicht so
eindrucksvoll war.
Ich habe ja das gerade extra gemacht,
weil man seinen Key immer mal wieder
neu erzeugt und sich einen neuen Key macht.
Pass auf zum Beispiel übrigens auf,
das Kommentarfeld von MKEY ist übrigens auch öffentlich.
Ich kenne Leute, die haben da reingeschrieben,
No Password, weil sie dachten, der Kommentar ist halt privat
nur für sich. Scheiße, wenn dir jemand
die Message signiert,
du schaust dir hier, warum hat denn der als Kommentar
No Password dran stehen?
Ja, aber ist ja egal,
was das Passwort von MKEY ist.
Naja, logisch, aber wenn du halt
weißt, dass der Nutzer kein Passphrase vergeben hat,
dann vielleicht eher eine persönliche Info.
Das kannst du ja nachträglich noch machen.
Einerseits das, andererseits
brauchst du natürlich für den Angriff mehr als das.
Die Passphrase selbst schützt es nicht, aber
es ist natürlich... Die Passphrase schützt bloß die Datei auf deiner
Platte. Natürlich, natürlich. Aber es
ist halt witzig, wenn du es halt damit
reinpackst. Gott, der Passwort in den Kommentar packt,
das wäre halt blöd.
So ein bisschen wie Blockchain, ne?
Wenn du jetzt, wenn du deinen Key hochlädst
und da ein Kommentarfeld drin ist und das tonnenweise
Leute, weil du ständig auf solche
Key-Signing-Partys rennst,
tonnenweise Leute signieren,
dann hast du da ein Stückchen Informationen,
was halt mehrfach
abgesignet wurde von Leuten und dementsprechend
schwer kaputt zu kriegen ist.
Gab es denn nicht mal irgendein Projekt, das
aufgrund deiner Keysignaturen und vor allem der
Signaturdaten eben dir
deine
Crypto Party History eben anzeigt,
mit welchen Leuten du dich wann getroffen hast
und bestenfalls an irgendeiner Stelle kriegst du noch
eine Information, wo das war und dann kriegst du
sogar raus, in welchen Dunstkreisen du abhängst.
Ja, PGP ist halt
nicht dafür geeignet, deine Privatsphäre zu
sichern, sondern nur deine Inhalte.
Ja, genau, das stimmt. Also interessanter,
wichtiger ist jetzt eigentlich nicht,
vielen Zusammenhängen, dass die Inhalte
deiner Nachrichten geheim sind, sondern dass
die Kommunikation, die Metadaten,
greifen wir nur die Metadaten ab für die Inhalte.
Die Metadaten sind überhaupt nicht verschlüsselt.
Gibt es Protokolle, bei denen
die Metadaten komplett sicher sind?
Lass ich mal so ein
Messaging-System,
was komplett auf
BitCompass ist, das ist auch Quatsch.
Da hast du die Metadaten richtig lange
festgenommen. Du meinst BitMessage?
BitMessage, BitMessage. Das gab es mal.
Das war Blockchain-basiert.
Du hast halt Nachrichten von anderen auf der Welt die ganze Zeit mit signiert und mitgehasht
und hast die somit in der öffentlichen Blockchain festgehalten, welche Nachrichten existieren.
Und ja, letztendlich hast du komplett, du hast an eine Adresse geschrieben
und nur diese Adresse konnte es halt letztendlich genau an der Stelle wie PGP.
Der hat mir das früher mal erklärt, du verschickst ein geöffnetes Schloss.
Der andere schreibt seine Nachricht, hängt das Schloss dran, aber nur du hast den Schlüssel.
Schön, dass du es mir erklärt hast.
Nee, ich wollte es dir nicht erklären,
ich wollte uns dieses Beispiel mit reinbringen,
das BitMessage funktioniert genauso wie PGP,
was ja dieselbe Idee ist.
Wenn du es halt ständig, wenn du es halt so ein Blockchain-Verfahren hast,
da hast du die Metadaten halt auf 1000 Jahre
festgenagelt und du kannst dich absolut nicht mehr,
wenn dir einer nachgewiesen hat,
dass du einmal mit dieser Adresse was gemacht hast,
dann kannst du das nie wieder abstreiten.
Das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem auch bei Bitcoin.
Bitcoin ist nicht anonym.
Leute nennen es
pseudo-anonym.
Die Idee des Best Practice ist halt auch für jede Transaktion einen neuen Key zu generieren
und dein Geld generell wahllos durch die Kante zu schaufeln,
dass es halt einfach nicht möglich ist, das nachzuvollziehen, welche Adressen dir gehören.
Und wenn du bei einer rausfindest, welche deine ist, dann kannst du da nicht auf die anderen schließen.
Also es gibt einen schönen Messenger, der heißt Ricochet.
Ricochet.
Kommt da der Name?
Nee, Ricochet heißt abprallen.
Ja, das kann ich aber nicht, dass das weiß ein Messenger ist, deshalb Rico-Chat.
Nee, der heißt
R-I-C-O-C-H-E-T.
Das ist kein
Panda, ist kein Chat mit drin.
Nicht wirklich, das wäre
eklig. Das ist ein
auf dem
Tor Netzwerk basierender
Chat-Client,
wo du dir solche schönen
Ricochet-Doppelpunkt und dann
eine
kryptische Zahl hin und her schickst und das ist quasi
quasi eine Onion-Adresse
und die Nachrichten werden
dezentral
übers Onion-Netz geroutet,
ganz normal. Du bist ein Teilnehmer,
du bist quasi ein Tor-Network-Client
und
du musst dir nur diese Adresse einmal austauschen
und die Nachrichten kommen bei dir an
und
im Gegensatz zu BitMessage
kannst du, wenn du diese
Adresse wegschmeißt, kannst du nicht
mehr nachweisen, dass du
diese Adresse benutzt hast.
Da gab es ja BitMessage,
also BitMessage ist ja eh tot, aber da gab es glaube ich irgendwas
eingebautes, dass du deinen Privkey im Netzwerk
veröffentlichst und damit eben
alles von dir legst, dass du
jemals da alleine Zugang zu hattest.
Aber dann machst du halt auch alle Nachrichten rückwirkend.
Public, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist eh tot. Über BitMessage
brauchen wir nicht mehr reden. Ja, also Ricochet ist vom
Konzept her ganz schön, es wurde auch auf dem letzten
Chaos Communication Kongress vorgestellt, oder auf dem vorletzten.
Ist allerdings
das ist wirklich der rudimentärste
Chat-Client, den du hier gesehen hast.
Das ist ein Feld oben und ein Feld unten.
Da kannst du was reintippen und da kannst du was senden.
Und du kannst, glaube ich, gerade so
eine Kontaktliste, wo du
den Leuten Namen geben kannst, was du aber
natürlich nicht solltest, weil wenn man das jemals findet,
dann weiß der mit dem gesprochen.
Gib deinen Leuten Pseudonyme.
Also am besten
du installierst dir Ricochet,
generierst dir so eine
Adresse
Stück Esspapier und gibt sie jemandem
und der kann das dann aufessen.
Schön. Aber ich meine, Thor alleine ist ja
auch kein Garant für Privacy.
Du hast ja trotzdem genug,
der Nodes kontrolliert, das weißt du ja auch noch, wo die Leute sind.
Und da fällt mir ein wunderschönes Beispiel ein.
Das war mal eine amerikanische Uni,
die hatten eine Prüfung und
zur Zeit der Prüfung war eben eine Bombendrohung
in dem Gebäude, wo
die Prüfung stattfand. Und
die Uni hatte natürlich
rausfinden wollen, von wo die Bombendrohung kam,
hat halt gemerkt, oh, da findet gerade eine Prüfung
statt. Das liegt ja irgendwo ein bisschen
auf der Hand, dass das von einem Studenten
vielleicht kommen könnte, der nicht mitschreiben wollte.
Die Bombendrohung selbst kam aus dem Tornetz.
Das heißt, wir können nicht direkt schauen, wer das ist.
Schauen wir doch einfach mal spaßenshalber auf die
Studentenwohnheime. Oh, aus den Studentenwohnheimen
ging ausschließlich zwei Verbindungen ins
Netzwerk. Fragen wir doch mal die zwei Leute
und der eine hat halt sofort gestanden.
Ist halt blöd.
Aber was halt wieder diese
wieder dieses
Zitat von Bruce Schneier
untermalt, wenn alle Leute
Postkarten nutzen, dann ist der
Briefumschlag halt suspicious.
Das heißt, mehr Leute müssten Thor nutzen, damit
das alles eben für alle Leute besser
wird. Ich habe mal
eine Zeit lang Thor benutzt, um
mir YouTube-Videos anzugucken, die
ich in Deutschland nicht hätte gucken dürfen.
Und das habe ich einer Freundin erzählt, die sofort so
ach, für sowas benutzt du Thor,
du Schwein. Das habe ich aber auch
einem gemeinsamen Freund immer vorgeworfen, der darüber
daunlos gezogen. Weil du
überlastest ja das Netz damit.
Es stimmt irgendwie, aber ich benutze es halt
für ganz normale Sachen.
Ich habe es auch nicht die ganze Zeit
laufen irgendwie. Es geht mir auch
auf den Keks, weil wenn ich mein ganz normalen
Traffic da durchjage, dann habe ich einfach von meiner
DSL-Leitung fast nichts.
Das ist einfach zu langsam.
Das ist was Schall daran ist, das stimmt schon.
Man könnte sich, man müsste
mal was programmieren. Das gibt es bestimmt schon.
So einen kleinen Tor-Noise-Generator.
Also ein Client, der aufmacht, so ein bisschen Zeugs macht.
Ich meine, das lebt sogar schon.
Ich meine zumindest davon mal.
Also ihr könnt mir zum Beispiel, ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass ich in meinem Haus eine Kiste habe,
die mirroert mir meine
Arch Linux Pakete übers Tornetz
irgendwie zu zufälligen
Zeiten am Tag, mehrmals am Tag.
Macht damit ein bisschen Traffic
auf dem Tornetz, nicht viel.
Und sowas.
Man könnte Radio,
Internetradio über das Tornetzwerk hören,
Das macht auch ein bisschen kontinuierliches Grundrauschen.
Bisschen Bitcoin meinen,
nicht mehr Bitcoin meinen, wieder ein bisschen Bitcoin.
Bitcoin ist doch auch,
nicht tot, aber Bitcoin meinen kannst du vergessen.
Das ist doch nichts mehr für Privatpersonen
oder kein Unternehmen.
Benutzt du noch Bitcoin?
Ich benutze es noch sehr aktiv.
Ich habe jetzt zum ersten Mal
meinen E-Mail-Anbieter nicht mit Bitcoin bezahlt,
weil da eben mein Echtman-Klarname
in dem Account steht.
Das letzte Mal habe ich es immer per Bitcoin bezahlt.
Momentan wüsste ich gar nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Ich nutze es aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen tatsächlich.
Und manchmal bietet es sich halt auch im echten Leben noch schön an.
Also im echten Leben, im Internetleben nutze ich es halt regelmäßig für ein paar Dinge.
Ich war letztens, das ist schon wieder ein bisschen her mit meiner Schwester mal in London.
Und da kam man tatsächlich einen Bürgerladen gefunden, einen sehr leckeren Bürgerladen.
Werteleinig, wie wer hier ist, um Schleichwerbung dafür zu machen.
Das war aber im Fall ein privater Ding und nicht eine Kette.
Da habe ich mit Bitcoin zahlen können.
Das fand ich super, weil ich eben
mein Bitcoin-Pfund hatte ich
gerade nicht parat in der Hand.
Internet hatte ich, weil EU.
Und das fand ich sehr angenehm und nutzt es tatsächlich sehr gerne sowas.
Kann man nicht mittlerweile in England
auch überall mit Apple Pay bezahlen?
Ja, aber Apple Pay kannst du halt vergessen,
wenn du Deutscher bist.
Du musst dir halt vorher irgendwann
den Account angelegt haben.
Internet hattest du bei EU?
Ja, ich habe einen schönen Tarif, wo ich in der ganzen EU
mein Datenvolumen nutzen kann.
Das finde ich sehr angenehm.
Und habe ich auch schon so oft genutzt, dass ich meine, das hat sich rentiert.
Cool.
Ich bin aber auch am Überlegen, meinen Mobilfunkvertrag beim pinken Riesen zu wechseln
gegen einen Prepaid-Minimalvertrag, weil man braucht ja auch so ein Ding mit einer Telefonnummer,
weil es Dienste gibt, die sich anhand deiner Telefonnummer identifizieren.
Eigentlich zum Kotzen, eine Telefonnummer könnte man abschalten,
Aber es gibt halt noch sowas wie WhatsApp, Twitter und Signal,
die aus irgendeinem Grund eine Telefonnummer benutzen, um dich zu identifizieren.
Also ich brauche noch was mit einer Telefonnummer, wo ich damit nie telefoniere.
Und dann habe ich überlegt, dass ich mir einen zweiten Account,
der extra so ein Tablet-Account ist, wo du nicht mit telefonieren kannst, noch reinholen.
Mit meinem Telefon kann ich zwei SIM-Karten reinstecken.
Und dann verstrahle ich mir dann meine Hoden doppelt, wenn ich irgendwie zwei SIM-Karten drin habe.
Es gibt Studien, die besagen, dass du dir sehr groß das Krebsrisiko in deiner Lendengegend steigerst mit dem Handy.
Und es gibt auch Studien, die sagen, dass du das Krebsrisiko eindämmst in der Lendengegend durch Handystrahlung.
Und da gibt es noch nichts Definitives.
Weil die Handystrahlung gleichzeitig auch die Krebsfällen abtötet?
Wirklich? Also ich habe Studien, wie gesagt, in beider Richtungen gelesen.
Das ist natürlich genauso aussagekräftig wie gefährliches Halbwissen,
wie wenn wir jetzt über Chemtrails reden oder sonst was.
Aber nee, keine Ahnung.
Also da möchte ich nicht dran glauben.
dass du dir das Risiko einziehst.
Apropos Krebsrisiko steigern.
Der heutige Podcast ist übrigens
auch sehr gesteigert worden, muss ich sagen.
Mal schön einen Kuss ansteigern.
Oh, das war ein schlechter Wort für den Kopf.
Der kam tief.
Oh Mann.
Also, Folge 3.
Nicht nur mit Kilian und Hendrix,
sondern mit Kilian, Hendrix und Steiger.
Folge 2, nicht 3.
Pass auf, wir machen das einfach so.
Wir reden jetzt schon so lange.
Wir schneiden die Folge in Haft.
Wir machen gleich Folge 3 mit raus.
Wir sind bei knapp über einer Stunde.
Das ist völlig legitim.
Wir machen jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange,
würde ich behaupten.
Dann haben wir eine gute Folge zusammen.
Das sind so die Sätze, die du sagst,
wenn der Podcast jetzt noch vier Stunden geht.
Wir nehmen jetzt ihr Telefon aus der Tasche,
gucken auf die Zeit und sehen,
warte mal, das sind erst 20 Prozent.
Die Zuhörer wissen ja, wie lange noch ist.
Wir nicht.
Ihr guckt jetzt und sagt,
aha, ihr lügt.
Ihr redet jetzt bestimmt noch bis,
naja, nächstes Jahr schon abends.
Ja, wir sind ja
quasi berufstätig.
Aber wir haben gerade so eine kleine, elegant weggeschnittene
Pause gemacht und in der haben wir gerade
alle nochmal eine neue Mate auf den Tisch gestellt
bekommen.
Ich glaube, ich nehme meine mit für morgen auf Arbeit.
Wunderbar, das ist ja schade, wenn man auf Arbeit
keine Koller bekommt.
Ich habe ja echt überlegt, ob ich mal
zu einem gegebenen Anlass
einfach mal ein, zwei Kästen selber mitbringe
und da eine Kühlestelle.
Schon wie lange das hält?
Das würde sich anbieten.
Ne, nochmal kurz Themenschnitt zum letzten Fuck-Up der Woche,
damit wir zumindest das noch durchhaben.
Cloudbleed, ein Stichwort.
Tragischerweise derjenige, der das ins Leben gerufen hatte,
ich glaube, es war auf einer Chromium-Mailing-Liste oder Google irgendwas,
hatte gleich als ersten Satz geschrieben,
dass er sehr getemptet war, das Cloudbleed zu nennen,
aber es nicht gemacht hat.
Aber trotzdem ist es unter dem Titel bekannt geworden.
Ist ein witziger Fuck-Up von Cloudflare.
Ich habe hier einen Exploit, bitte nenne ich das nicht Cloudbleed.
Wir wissen sowas sonst nicht.
Ich meine, es geht um Daten, gerade aus verdüsselten Sessions,
die eben geleakt wurden.
Da liegt irgendwas mit Bleed natürlich auf der Hand.
Ja, ich meine, das liegt in der Tradition von Hardbleed.
Also wenn du ein guter Exploit sein möchtest heutzutage,
hast du einen catchy Namen und ein Logo.
Oh, ein Logo machst natürlich noch viel mehr.
Und oder einen Werbefilm.
Ein Cloudbleed hat eine blutende Wolke als Logo.
Wunderschön.
Heartbeat hat ja dieses blutende, tropfende Herz.
Das Heartbeat-Logo war tatsächlich noch das Schickste.
Das war schick.
Die Xbox, die es ja danach so gab,
mir fällt jetzt dieser mit der Cow nicht mehr ein.
Es gab noch Pudel.
Okay.
Ich hatte einen Zähnefletschenden Pudel als Logo.
Mein Heartbeat ist jetzt noch nicht alt.
Das war ja vorhin, da gab es ein Jahr oder so.
Zwei.
Echt? Zu lang schon?
Heartbeat ist lang her.
Es gab zuletzt eine Auswertung.
Welche Server denn noch verwirrtbar sind?
Das kam auf feisert sogar.
auf SAD waren die News.
Deutschland war, glaube ich, sogar auf Platz 2.
Ganz viel bei 1 und 1.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Qualitätshosting.
Qualitätshosting, unbedingt das Qualitätshosting.
Und das Interessante waren die Kombinationen,
welche Systeme da wie verwundbar waren.
Da waren uralte Tomcat-Versionen.
Ja, den Blick habe ich auch gemacht.
So ein hochgezogenes Augenbrauch,
die schon HDTV 2 können.
Und wir so, what?
What the fuck?
Ja, und gegen OpenSSL
von sonst wann mit einer APR-Library
liefen, also
Native Code ausführen konnten
für SSL und die haben dann das
OpenSSL-Hauptlied-Loch
auch gehabt. Aber hat die B2
abkönnen.
Das war richtig gruselig.
Da muss man mal reinschauen und dann
in den Statistiken schauen, was da für
Kombinationen dann kommen.
Finde ich mir interessiert, da noch mal mehr reinzulesen.
Wir haben H2
als Protokoll.
Das krasse an CloudBeat ist ja, dass es diesen Anbieter,
damit es Cloudflare gibt, dem sehr viele Webseiten sich vorschalten,
damit der Request von einer, wenn eine Person jetzt auf meine Webseite geht,
der Request erstmal an Cloudflare und Cloudflare schickt die weiter an mein Server,
wenn sie der Meinung sind, das ist so der...
Das ist so ein CDN, oder?
Einerseits das, das ist der Use Case von Cloudflare,
wenn mein Server down geht und ich habe erstmal nur statische Assets und so weiter,
dann bleibt meine Seite online für alle Leute, die Cloudflare nutzen.
Das ist eigentlich als Feature her ganz praktisch. Andererseits filtert Cloudflare halt malicious Traffic eben raus. Also wenn jemand einen DDoS gegen meinen Service fährt, dann kann mir Cloudflare sehr gut dabei helfen, diesen DDoS eben von meinen Servern fernzuhalten.
Und wie gesagt, das ist sehr praktisch. Das große Problem, was ich schon immer mit Cloudflare hatte, ist, dass sie natürlich meinen kompletten Traffic man in the middle attacken und ihr eigenes SSL injecten. Und du kannst auch so creepy Sachen machen, dass du Google Analytics über Cloudflare in den Site-Source mit injectest und trotzdem natürlich über SSL das rausgeht, weil die halt dann ihr SSL-Service nutzen, um deine Seite zu signieren. Es ist unglaublich creepy.
Was? Man in the middle as a service.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, ja essentiell genau das. Das macht eben Cloudflare alles ein bisschen creepy. Was Cloudflare eben verkackt hat an der Stelle, ist, dass sie teilweise private Daten, wenn ich jetzt mit einem Cloudflare-Server rede und da eben Daten schickt, mein Post-Request über sonst wie, mein Passwort-Kram mit drin steht oder Session-IDs oder was auch immer, dass sie das halt auf ihrem Server blöderweise irgendwie einen Buffer-Overflow hatten und den Kram halt teilweise an andere Cloudflare-Server.
dass gehostete Seiten halt mit rausgegeben haben,
die halt da waren,
zufällig an dem selben Server liefen
und zum Beispiel rede ich jetzt mit einer Seite
in Seite A und schicke mein Passwort zu denen
und ein anderer Kunde lädt von einer komplett anderen Seite B
irgendwie die Daten runter
und kriegt halt in dem Output
meinen privaten Content mit drin.
In der HTTP-Response.
Das ist so die Grundidee,
das ist das Blitz erklären.
Das ist kein Cloud-Bleed,
sondern ein Cloud-Splatter, oder?
Und was halt richtig eklig an der Sache ist,
ist, dass dieser Content halt von Search-Engines
mit geindext und gecashed wird.
Das heißt, es kann sein, dass Google halt diversen
privaten Kram von tausenden von Leuten
da eben gerade hostet und auch verteilt an andere.
Und das ist halt echt
schwierig. Man weiß halt überhaupt nicht, was das
alles beeinflusst und wo
die Daten gelandet sind. Das kann niemand einschätzen
und man wird es halt auch nicht wissen, was
du jetzt machen kannst. Passwörter ändern und
Sessions invalidaten und sonst was. Ich weiß auch
nicht zwangsläufig mit welchen Diensten
ich zu tun habe, die mit Outbleed
von Cloudflare
weiterverbreitet worden.
Viele, mehr als du denkst.
Mir blutet auch gerade so ein bisschen das Herz, dass du über meinen
Wortwitz so eiskalt... Oh, schön, da habe ich verpasst.
Wenn das
deine Privatinformation nicht einfach
bloß irgendwo rausblutet,
sondern zufällig an andere Leute
verteilt, dann ist es eher Cloudsplatter.
Übrigens,
Heartbleed wurde
2014 veröffentlicht.
Das ist also schon drei Jahre alt fast.
Krass.
ich muss gerade an den Film Werner Beinhardt denken
wo Brösel
den Entwurf zum Studio
schicken will und der Typ dann in der Post
die Postmarken
vertauscht und sein Comic
landet bei einem Typen
in Sibirien
und das Münchner
Comicstudio kriegt dann die Wärmeflaschen
die eigentlich für den Typen für Sibirien bestimmt
war
das ist halt ein massiver
Fuck-up auf Seiten von Cloudflare
Und die jegliche Restform von Trust, die sie so hatten,
sind meiner Meinung nach komplett zerfallen.
Und ich will Cloudflare nie wieder, muss ich sagen, nutzen.
Und ich hoffe, andere Leute sehen auch ein bisschen davon ab,
obwohl sie halt für manche Anwendungsfälle
echt einen praktischen Dienst eben haben.
Ich musste gerade an das Wallowoods Human Waste Distribution System.
Das war mal Big Bang Theory.
Das war eigentlich Wallowoods Human Waste Disposal System.
Heißt das, das war so eine Space Toilette,
die leider irgendwann übergelaufen ist und dann
explodiert ist. Das ist die ganze Kacke
rausgehalten, deswegen wurde es dann umgetaucht,
wenn das more than words, human waste distributions ist.
Soviel zum zweiten Fuck-up der Woche.
Also, Krypto, das war
wirklich ein Fuck-up. Also, wenn jemand Krypto
bricht, die schon seit einem Jahr deprecated
ist, dann ist das eigentlich
ein I told you so.
Aber
wenn ein Cloud-Anbieter
sagt, wir machen hier eine sichere
Vorschaltseite für deinen Dienst und dann
gettern die deine Secrets quer über das Internet,
dann ist das tatsächlich ein Fuck-up der Woche.
Ja, aber sowas...
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an Cloudflare.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir euch genug Themen gegeben,
die ihr nachlesen und uns korrigieren könnt in den Kommentaren.
Habt bestimmt erst mal eine halbe Stunde zu tun,
unsere Fähre herauszufinden
und uns die korrekten Fakten in die Kommentarspalte zu schreiben.
Also wir freuen uns auf euer Feedback.
Die Chapter-Marks werden spannend für die Folge.
Also sehr viel Language-Nerdery am Anfang
und alles komplett durcheinander.
Vielleicht kann man die ja einfach,
kann man bei den Language, bei den Chapter-Marks
auch eine Reihenfolge angeben, da macht man direkt so eine Playlist
draus und der Podcast wird out of order abgespielt,
sodass es semantisch wieder Sinn ergibt.
Oh Gott.
Nee, damit fangen wir nicht an.
Wir kommen lieber, meditieren nicht mehr hinterher.
So, das war Folge
zwei
von Akronomisierbar, diesmal
vor einem Live-Publikum in der
Infofakultät aufgenommen. Wir bedanken uns
bei unserem Gast Steiger.
Vielen Dank. Du musst mal
wiederkommen und mehr
über den geilen Scheiß, den du so machst, reden.
Ja, sehr gerne. Weil das ist wirklich
beeindruckender Kram.
Okay, danke für das
Kontinente. Ich bin gerne mit dabei.
Also zukünftige Folgen
mit anwesenden Personen.
Also nochmal, vielen Dank, dass ihr bis hier
durchgehalten habt. Respekt.
Wir haben doch fast Versprechen gehalten.
Wir haben nicht viel länger gemacht, als ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Das ist erst vor ein paar Minuten gewesen.
Anderthalb Stunden, das ist gut.
Es ist zum Beispiel, wenn ihr jetzt Sonntagabend
mit eurer Familie da sitzt und die Tatort gucken wollen,
könnt ihr gleichzeitig diesen Podcast anmachen
und eure Zeit damit totschlagen,
dass ihr zwar Tatort guckt, aber akronomisierbar hört.
Diss du gerade den Tatort?
Und dass gerade, wo der Dresdner Tatort
wirklich ins Leben gerufen wurde,
ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
Was gibt ihn?
Echt?
Zu scheiße?
Okay, gemein.
Der ist quasi, ich möchte fast behaupten, der ist so feministisch, dass er schon umgekehrt sexistisch ist.
Okay.
Aber ich mache jetzt hier nicht noch weitere Fesse auf.
Also nochmal, das war Akronomisierbar Folge 2 mit Kilian.
Und Henrik.
Und Steiger.
Hey.
Ciao, macht's gut, viel Spaß beim nächsten Podcast in eurer Playlist.
Bis dann.